Und zwar so ein Premium-Spiel, aber...
Was ist denn das jetzt für einer?
Ja, ist sie sehr gut integriert. Ich finde auch gerade diese Integration total charming, weil durch dieses Health-Subsystem von iOS sind halt vor allem auch alle miteinander verbunden. Also da hat sich jetzt auch so in den letzten Update-Zyklen in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren noch eine ganze Menge getan. Also zum Beispiel RunTastic, was ich zum Beispiel benutze fürs Laufen, fürs Tracken. Weil das halt anders jetzt als die Apple-eigenen Sachen auch GPS aufzeichnet. Das für mich einfach, weiß ich nicht, also ohne würde ich gar nicht erst anfangen.
Ja genau, heißt fürs Fahrradfahren jetzt auch hier dieses Cycle.
Ja gut, also für Touren und so weiter ist das ja nochmal was anderes. Aber jetzt auch beim Laufen, ich will halt auch aufzeichnen, wo ich lange laufen will, zumal man das dann in der Kombination mit einem Herzrhythmussensor dann einfach den Vorteil hat, dass du, wie sagt man, nicht Herzrhythmus, Herzpulsmesser, also mit einem Pulsmesser, dass du dann eben auch einfach sehen kannst, da waren die Belastungen größer für dich und dann kannst du das halt auch ganz gut korrelieren mit deiner Erinnerung an die Strecke. Als wenn du jetzt nur irgendwie so eine prozentuale Aufstellung oder irgendwelche Mittelwerte oder sowas bekommst und man weiß einfach so, da ging die Pumpe und dann kannst du dich auch dran erinnern.
Genau, und das war ich halt dieses Cycle-Meter. Irgendwie ist so die Fahrrad-Track-App da, die jetzt so irgendwie im App Store ganz vorne mit dabei war. Und die hat halt alles so Geschwindigkeit und die verschiedenen Etappen und Ort und Wetter. Hast du nicht gesehen, aber der entscheidende Teil dann auch so, weil ich schon relativ sportlich auch dann teilweise mit dem Radl fahre, da würde ich dann auch schon gerne wissen, wo, an welcher Stelle oder wie lange war da welche Belastung am Start?
Ja, aber was ich gerade noch vergessen hatte, jetzt abschließend zu sagen, zu meiner Aussage, dass das ja alles gut integriert sei, also ich kann jetzt mit Runtastic meine Workouts tracken, aber die sind dann nicht nur in Runtastic, sondern die landen dann quasi auch als Workouts in der iOS-Datenbank. Das heißt, ich kann auch mit allen anderen Tools, also alles kann aufeinander zugreifen. Also Runtastic kann sich den Pulsmesser von der Uhr holen, kippt aber selber seine Workops damit rein. Das heißt, selbst wenn ich jetzt in der Health-App meinen Überblick mache über alles Mögliche, tauchen dort alle Workouts auf, egal mit welcher App ich das gemacht habe. Das finde ich eigentlich cool, weil dadurch dieser App-Login wegfällt mittelfristig. Man benutzt dann sozusagen für alles das Beste, aber man hat trotzdem noch die Möglichkeit, einen Überblick über alles zu bekommen. Das ist schon ganz charmant. Trotzdem ist da noch einiges zu holen. Aber ich finde jetzt auch gerade mit der Apple Watch macht Laufen noch mal mehr Spaß, weil ich eben auch den ganzen Kram über die Uhr starten kann. Was enorm hilft, wenn du dein Telefon eigentlich beim Laufen ja gar nicht mehr groß bedienen willst.
Oder mit verschwitzten Händen irgendwie Laufen beenden. Genau, das wäre halt auch das nächste. Weil immer wenn ich jetzt Fahrrad fahre eine Runde und mir extra obenweg ausdenke, dann Telefon aus der Tasche, App starten, neue Strecke und dann beim Aufhören wieder ausmachen. Das sind halt dann so die Sachen. Allerdings muss ich sagen, das was ich an dieser Held-App zu kritisieren habe ist, ich finde Usability mäßig das eine totale Katastrophe. Ich musste googeln, wie man das Dashboard konfiguriert. Und mir war nicht klar, wie ich aus meiner Cycle-App die Stats, die da offensichtlich landen, wie ich die tatsächlich auf dem Dashboard sehen kann. Und das war aus dem User-Interface mir nicht intuitiv ersichtlich, wie das zu bewerkstelligen war. Und dann musste ich danach googeln. Und das alleine, auch wie das so strukturiert ist und wie man an die jeweiligen Informationen dann sich da durchhangeln muss und wieder zurück, wenn man auf einen anderen Pfad will.
Dass man drehen kann, weißt du auch schon, ja? Dass dann die Ansicht kommt, wo man ein bisschen warten muss, weil die dann neu berechnet, dass man da schön zoomen kann und so.
Ja, guter Tipp, aber ich finde, also hätten sie sich schon noch ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben können mit.
Also zum Thema Uhr nochmal, man muss halt bedenken, die ist halt auch ein bisschen fragil.
Ah, neues Thema.
Eine galante Überleitung.
Was hast du eigentlich im Urlaub gemacht, Tero?
Du hast nämlich gerade eben, dachte ich mir so, ja, hat die Uhr eigentlich ihr Ableben noch aufgezeichnet? Und sie hat, also dieser eine Spike hier in dem Bewegen und Trainieren ist tatsächlich das Fußballspiel, wo es dann ungefähr in Minute fünf zu dem Faul kam, das mich irgendwie auf den Teerboden gelegt hat und nicht nur die Hand so ein bisschen angestaucht, sondern eben die Uhr auch zerstört.
Du hast es wirklich geschafft, deine Apple Watch zerstören zu lassen durch einen Fußballfaul, dessen Opfer du warst. Du wurdest gefault.
Ich wurde gefault, ja, von hinten das Bein gestellt. Und wenn man gerade irgendwie am Beschleunigen ist, um den Ball noch zu kriegen, bevor er ins Aus geht, dann ist das halt irgendwie, dann hat man so eine gewisse Wucht und ja, so auf Teer spielen, das ist halt auch nur so eine mittlere Idee, aber naja.
Was hat dich überhaupt in deinem Alter dazu gebracht, Fußball zu spielen?
Ach so, ich sollte vielleicht noch eine Runde... Ja, wir hatten zur WM hatten wir in der Firma so ein Tippspiel. Da dieses, ne, im Sommer war da mit den Fußballern und so. Die WM war eine EM, du hast richtig. Du hast recht, ja ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall hab ich mich an einem Tippspiel beteiligt und habe also gerade so in der Gruppenphase erstaunlich oft richtig geraten. Und lag dann punktemäßig so weit vorne, dass es also tatsächlich noch für den dritten Platz gereicht hat. Und als Preis für den dritten Platz gab es halt einen Fußball und zwei Fußballtore. Also so kleine, zeltartige Fußballtore ungefähr so halben Meter hoch, einen Meter breit. So ein bisschen kleiner wie Eishockey, mit so Karbonstangen zum Hinstellen. Genau, und dann haben wir in der Firma dann eben halt auch diese Fußballtore und den Ball ausprobiert. Beim ersten Spiel war ich noch nicht dabei. Da hat es irgendwie unseren mexikanischen Mitarbeiter gut hingelegt. Der hatte irgendwie den halben Rücken offen. Tja, und beim zweiten Spiel hat es mich dann zerlegt. Ein weiteres Spiel war noch nicht.
Die Apple Watch Blutgrätsche.
Und die Uhr war so richtig zerscheppert, kaputt im Eimer oder wie oder was? Naja, also was genau war jetzt kaputt? Nur das Glas?
Jaja, nur das Glas. Also die Uhr, die tat dann schon noch, aber ich habe sie dann nicht weiter getragen, weil ich das Gefühl hatte, also wenn da jetzt noch mehr Belastung draufkommt, dann bröselt dir nach und nach irgendwie die Scheibe von der Uhr runter. Und ich wollte jetzt auch kein dickes Tape drauf tun, deswegen habe ich sie...
Das ist jetzt schon das zweite Mal, dass du mit einer komplett zerstörten Apple Watch in den Laden reingelaufen bist.
Die ist nicht komplett zerstört, guck mal, sie budelt sogar noch. Man konnte sogar noch irgendwie die Force Touch ging noch und so weiter. Also so funktional war sie noch nicht komplett kaputt.
Wie stark muss man sich diesen Schlag vorstellen, den du so ausgeübt hast mit der Uhr auf dem Boden? Also wenn ich das jetzt versuchen würde...
Naja, es reicht dazu, dass ich jetzt halt immer noch mit einer Schiene am Arm...
Naja, dass da schon eine gewisse Energie drin war, schon. Aber wenn ich jetzt so... Ist das so vergleichbar mit... Ich schmeiße das Ding mit voller Geschwindigkeit, was ich so kann, auf den Boden oder... Eher nicht. Weißt du, den Arm so runterfallen zu lassen, während man liegt oder...
Eher nicht. Und ich weiß auch nicht mehr genau, wie es passiert ist. Also ich bin halt...
Er ist nochmal raufgetreten.
Ich habe keine Erinnerung, euer Ern.
Naja, ich bin halt mit dem rechten Knie aufgekommen. Allerdings nicht so stark, weil ich die meiste Kraft eben mit dem Handgelenk abgefangen habe. Aber ich habe mich halt dann auch abgerollt.
Die Apple Watch hat dich gerettet.
Eventuell. Ich glaube, ich bin über die Apple Watch abgerollt.
Eigentlich hat die Apple Watch so einen kleinen Airbag irgendwo eingebaut.
Zumindest hat das Armand gehalten. Also Melanie's Loop bin ich nach wie vor großer Fan von.
Fahrstühle, Glastüren und Fußballspiele. Roddy, du hast ja schon ganz schön was zusammengefegt bekommen. Ich hatte schon lange keinen Nenzwettenunfall mehr. Ich hab auch kein besonderes Bedürfnis, muss ich dazu sagen. Aber wir nehmen Anteil.
Irgendjemand schrieb Roddies Leben eine Aneinanderreihung von denkwürdigen Ereignissen rund ums Glas.
Das kann man, glaube ich, so stehen lassen. So, wir sind ja wieder, Klammer zu, Klammer zu, Klammer zu, wieder zurück zum Urlaubsthema.
Letty war auch im Urlaub.
Letty war in mehreren Urlauben. Angefangen irgendwie Schweden. Also ich war wandern.
Da war ich auch.
Ach, du auch? Ja. Schweden, kurz mal rüber nach Dänemark und wieder Schweden. Ja, jetzt muss ich mir überlegen, was ich da gemacht habe. Ja, eigentlich nur gewandert. Ich hab ja irgendwie immer so den Drang. Hallo, Schweden? Hast du mein Foto gesehen, was ich dir... Ich glaube, das hab ich dir so geschickt. In Schweden kommt man an Wanderwegen lang. Im Nichts. Und da steht dann so ein Schild, irgendwo ist ein Haus. Ja, dieses Haus hat irgendwie schnelles Internet. Und hast du überall dann da stehen. So eine Schilder, dass die Häuser schnelles Internet haben.
Mit den Zugangsdaten oder nur, dass man...
Nee, nee, nur. Das ist eigentlich für die Nachbarschaft. Was meinen sie damit? Ja, genau, damit die Nachbarschaft sieht. Oho, die haben schon schnell Glasfaser. Wir bekommen also auch bald welche. Das ist der ganze Witz dahinter. Also Schweden hat überall Internet, auch mit dem Telefon. Und ich habe so ein paar Schweden da kennengelernt. Mit denen war ich ein paar Tage unterwegs. Und die regten sich dann auf. Oh, wir haben schon wieder kein Internet. Aber ich habe doch Edge. Ja, das heißt kein Internet. Okay, wir sind ja nirgendwo. Wir haben kein Internet, ja.
Ja, in Norwegen gab es auch auf so Inseln und so eine Ubiquity-Station an die Tanne genagelt.
Darauf warte ich noch, dass dieser so ein Schweden hast du an den Wanderwegen. Häufig so Holzhütten, so eine Wetterschutz-Shelter. In denen schlafe ich halt auch meistens. Fehlt noch, dass man da irgendwie den WLAN-Router dran hat. Da warte ich noch drauf. Aber ich wette, das wird es in den nächsten Jahren auch noch geben.
Ich leise das Foto mal kurz in den Chat weiter.
Ja, aber es stimmt schon. Vor allen Dingen, diese Tarife sind doch relativ billig. Also du hast eine Woche Internet irgendwie für, was war es, 10 Euro und du kannst es einfach nicht verbrauchen in der Woche.
Okay, ich habe so eine Zubuchoption in meinem Vertrag für plus EU1.
Ah ja, genau, diese Schilder, die stehen überall rum. Allerdings nicht nur von der Firma.
Was heißt denn das genau, was da drauf steht?
Das heißt halt wirklich nur, dass du der Glasfaser-Internet, Glasfaser-Anschluss an diesem Haus hast. Und es gibt die in verschiedenen Farben, so nach dem Motto, das Haus hat schon, das Haus wird angeschlossen. Das heißt, dass das schnelle Faser an diesem Haus anliegt, glaube ich.
An Flutters mit Fiber ist wahrscheinlich angeschlossen.
Ja, genau.
Und Fast ist schnell.
Schnell und das Haus ist mit schnellem Internet. Das Haus?
Ja, also diese Schilder sind mir auch aufgefallen. Nein, man fährt da durch die Orte durch und überall stehen diese Dinger da. Ja, hier.
Die wollen nur die deutschen Touristen ärgern.
Ja, ich würde auch ein bisschen komisch angucken, dass ihr das Foto gemacht habt und so. Was denn? In Berlin ist man darüber sehr neidisch. Wir haben keine Glasfaser überall.
Doch, wir haben Glasfaser. Man kann sie nur nicht bezahlen, das ist das Problem. Also Glasfaser liegt hier überall unter der Erde. Das ist ja das Traurige daran.
Ja, das ist schlimm. Aber wo du sagtest, man bekommt Internet überall, ich musste mit Erschrecken feststellen, dass Monaco nicht zur EU zählt, weil der Täter kommt, bei Ländergruppe 1.
Der Test meint übrigens, das Schild heißt, soll angeschlossen werden.
Ach, dann ist das das mit dem angeschlossen werden. Es gibt zwei Farben auch irgendwie. Das eine sagt, es wird angeschlossen, und das andere sagt, es ist sogar schon angeschlossen.
Wir können auch mal solche Schilder im Presseverberg verteilen. Wird nie angeschlossen werden.
Es wird nie angeschlossen werden.
Es darf nicht angeschlossen werden.
Doch, bitte anschließen.
So Telekom-Schilder soll mit Glasfaser.
Aber das wäre natürlich auch schön, wenn man einfach so offiziell aussehende Telekom-Schilder überall in der Stadt verteilt.
Hier wird es bald.
Wenn der Telekom-Sprecher sagt, das ist auf gar keinen Fall wahr, was ist denn das?
Das können sie doch nicht machen.
Da müssen sie auch dann liefern. Das wäre doch vielleicht eine Strategie.
Wir sind gerade live.
Es ist eine Kunstaktion, da geht alles.
Ist Kunst.
Na klar, das finde ich gut.
Einfach so.
Jungs, ihr habt den Job.
Ihre Telekom, ab nächstes Jahr gibt es hier 10... Was hätte man denn heutzutage gerne?
Du musst das Anschlussdatum auch direkt dazugeschreiben.
So ein Gigabit symmetrisch...
Ab Mai.
Ab Mai 2017.
Ab April. Ab 1. April.
Ich bin diesmal ohne Blessuren zurückgekommen.
Anders als Roddy.
Aus dem Urlaub bin ich auch ohne Blessuren zurückgekommen.
Ich hatte letztes Jahr, äh, ich hatte ein bisschen Angst, ich war in Schweden an einer ähnlichen Stelle, ein kleines Déjà-vu mit dem Krankenhaus. Und diesmal hat es ohne geklappt. Sonst war eigentlich, also Schweden war irgendwie angenehm, ein bisschen Schweden, ein bisschen Dänemark, ein bisschen Schweden. Keine Menschen. Nur laufen, laufen, laufen.
Das war ganz gut.
Ja, das ist ja auch mal das Schöne auf dem Segelboot. Da gibt es immerhin sechs Menschen, aber ansonsten nicht so viel. Man kann auch, wenn man mal an Land musste, wegen Nahrungsmitteln, dann könnte man auch sich ganz schnell wieder von den Menschen entfernen. Das ist wirklich, also diese Land-Sickness, die setzt relativ schnell einen im Vergleich zur Seekrankheit bei mir.
Ja, das ist, das war irgendwie erstaunlich. Ich war halt kurz in Kopenhagen drüben, hab deine Freundin getroffen und irgendwie so aus der Natur wieder in so geschlossene Räume. Und du stehst vor so einer Tür und denkst so, was soll ich jetzt mit der Tür, was ist das für ein Konzept?
Kleiner Tipp aufmachen, das ist schmerzhaft.
Ja, es wackelt zum Glück keine Grastür.
Aber sonst keine digitalen Einschläge während dieser Zeit. Es war sozusagen alles komplett Digitalflucht.
Nee, ich hab schon ein bisschen Internet gehabt. Also wie gesagt, ich hab halt mir irgendwann mal den Luxus von dieser Ländergruppe eins, von der EU hier irgendwie, gegönnt. Und musste halt nur im anderen Urlaub schmerzlich feststellen, als ich mir so dachte, ach ja, fünf Tage, fünf Länder, das passt. Dass Monaco nicht zu der Ländergruppe gehört. Sauerei. Ja, man fährt halt mal schnell zum Mittagessen nach Monaco. Man guckt ein bisschen in den Jachten.
Aber ist Monaco nicht auch so klein, dass du sowieso immer die Antennen von den Nachbarländern reinkriegst?
Ja, komischerweise nicht von... Nee, hast du komischerweise nicht reingekriegt. Also ich hatte dann extra nochmal geschaut, ob ich französisches Netz bekomme. Keine Chance. Aber dann hab ich mir bei Gelegenheit auch mal die kläglichen Überreste des Driftkletschers angeschaut. Und da fällt mir deine Höhengeschichte ein. Ich hab mich nicht getraut, über die Driftbrücke wirklich drüber zu laufen.
Driftbrücke?
Ja, wir waren auch bei einem Gletscher mindestens. Aber die touristische Wanderwegsbeschreibung, die war ein paar Jahre alt.
Wollen wir kurz mal aufklären, worum es überhaupt geht? Driftbrücke, was?
Drift, mit T, R-I-F-T. Und Brücke, ähm, Ganttmann, äh, Ganttmann. In der schönen Schweiz. Die Driftbrücke, es ist eine Hängebrücke. So aus Drahtzellen und...
Und da rennt hat der...
Okay, ein Kugelörs nicht, aber...
Das ist ja hübsch. Ich kann da mal ein Foto von reinschmeißen.
Da hast du dich nicht rüber getraut?
Sagt mir gleich Google. Äh, nee, ich hab mich nicht rüber getraut. Weil... Ich weiß nicht, ich hätte halt hinten auf dem gegenüberliegenden Wanderweg wär ich nicht weitergekommen, weil es geht nur zu einer Hütte. Und es ist ein alpiner Wanderweg. Sieht schon sportlich aus. Ja, und dahinter ist ein alpiner Wanderweg. Ich mein, ich kenn mich vom Klettern, ich muss die Hände an irgendwas haben. Ich versuche irgendwie über diese Brücke zu gehen, diese Aussicht zu genießen und schnell wieder zurück zu gehen. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das muss ich jetzt hier nicht haben.
Du hast dich nicht getraut, über diese Brücke rüberzugehen? Du bist auf der einen Seite stehen geblieben und bist nicht weiter gelaufen.
Wir sind einen Wanderweg gelaufen, was ein Rundweg war.
Achja, seid gar nicht erst dahin gekommen.
Ja, doch, bis zu der Brücke schon. Aber der Wanderweg geht an der Brücke vorbei. Und du hast von der Brücke aus schon, also von diesem Plateau, wo du dich auffällst, hast du den Überblick auf den Gletschersee und den Gletscher. Und das war das Eigentliche, was ich sehen wollte. Wobei das schon noch ein bisschen mehr ist als jetzt.
Sieht aber schon sehr ordentlich aus, die Brücke.
Ja, die ist ordentlich, aber...
Na, es hat schon so was von Himalaya. Hängebaumelbrücke.
Ja, sie baumelte da nicht so extrem.
Sie war ja auch seitlich befestigt.
Na ja, die haben ja die Schweizer gebaut. Die machen ja Dinge richtig.
Die Neuseeland war nicht mal über so eine Brücke, aber die waren nicht ganz so hoch. Die war eher über so ein Fluss drüber, glaube ich.
Das ist so an dem Ende eines Gletschers.
Ich werde mir das beim nächsten Mal, glaube ich, gönnen, weil ich irgendwie diese alpine Wandertour mal noch irgendwann ausprobieren will. Aber die ist halt, da muss man das im Voraus buchen und nicht irgendwie morgens überlegen, wir könnten da mal hinfahren. Wir würden auch irgendwie, als wir da mal nachgefragt haben, wo wir da aussteigen müssen, so busmäßig, von einem etwas älteren Mann pickierlich begutachtet und gesagt haben, also nee, Kinder, ihr kommt hier um 11 an und ihr wollt jetzt da hoch, das geht ja schon gar nicht mehr, wie das so in der Schweiz ist.
Aber was du gerade meintest, war auch in Norwegen der Fall bei so einem Gletscher, dass die Touristen Informationstafeln meinten, naja, es dauert so und so lang, um da jetzt zum Gletscher zu kommen, aber die war schon ein paar Jahre alt und der Gletscher in der Zwischenzeit sehr viel kleiner. Beziehungsweise wir sind gar nicht dann bis ganz da an die Stelle, wo man das eigentlich hätte in voller Pracht sehen können, weil der schon arg geschrumpft ist in den letzten Jahren.
Ich kann das ja mal ein Foto davon reinschmeißen, das hab ich auf Wikipedia mal gefunden, wo man die eigentlichen Ausmaße dieses Gletschers sieht. Und kann Tim ja mal...
Ist das da auch so, dass unten der Gletscher total dreckiges Eis ankommt und oben ist der Gletscher richtig frisch weiß?
Das, was man gesehen hat auf dem... Also wenn man auf den abfallenden Gletscher geschaut hat, also Tim hat das ja gerade gezeigt, dahinter geht's ja noch weiter. Wie der aussieht, weiß ich nicht, aber auf das, was du schaust, ist super dreckig. Also dieses typische Phänomen, dass es einfach der Gletscher nicht mehr sauber genug ist, als dass er das Licht reflektieren kann.
Und dann dadurch wärmer wird.
Ja genau.
Das ist doch alles eine Frechheit.
Aber da sieht man ja, dass es oben scheinbar noch weitergeht. Das hab ich alles gar nicht gesehen. Ich weiß auch nicht, bis wohin der alpine Wanderweg geht. Ich glaub nicht, dass man über den Gletscher überhaupt drüber kommt. Was auch sehr spannend war, war die Beschreibung des Weges. Wir sind halt hoch ein Stück gefahren mit der Seilbahn. Zurück konnten wir aber nicht mehr mit der Seilbahn, weil die dann halt ausgebucht ist. Dann gab es so eine Wegbeschreibung, der ja hier bis zum Dorf runter, 2,5 Stunden. Es waren glücklicherweise keine 2,5 Stunden, sonst hätten wir das nicht geschafft. Aber ausgeschildert war es so als Wanderweg. Man muss halt drittsicher sein. Da dachten wir, okay, es ist halt ein Wanderweg. Na ja, in der Stelle hoch ging schon mehr Klettern. Also mit so ein bisschen Befestigung, aber wenn man klettert, braucht man das nicht. Das war das erste, wo ich mir dachte, okay, interessanter Weg. Und bergab ging eigentlich alles durch ein Flussbett. Und nicht nur ein trockenes Flussbett, sondern ein schön nasses Flussbett. Und fließendes Wasser. Und es waren teilweise Stellen, wo man knöchelhoch im Wasser stand. Okay, das ist ja ein normaler Wanderweg. Ich möchte nicht wissen, wie die Alpinenwanderwege aussehen.
Dass der Vierwaldstädter Säte mit ihnen gerade...
Wenn es bei Luzern ist, dann ja.
Ich wollte mich gerade mal so ein bisschen vergegenwärtigen, wo denn das hier eigentlich alles ist. Und hab gleich mal ein paar Stellen abgefahren, die ich kannte. Aber bis zu dieser Triffbrücke hab ich es nicht geschafft. Ich bin überhaupt selten in der Schweiz. Zu selten in der Schweiz.
In der Luzern war ich auch schon mal. Und dann auf irgendeinem hohen Berg. Aber frag mich nicht mehr, welcher.
Gibt es ja mehrere zur Auswahl.
Ja, da gibt es keinen Mangel.
Na gut, also du hast auf jeden Fall Natur genossen und in allen Formen und Farben.
Ja, ein Tag Berge und den nächsten Tag dann schön am Meer rumgehangen.
Dennis, hast du denn Urlaub gemacht? Das ist nicht so dein Ding.
Kinderzeit.
Ja, so ist das manchmal.
Was?
Weiß nicht, war das schon alles?
Wenn ich Urlaub mache, fahre ich Motorrad.
Das hast du aber jetzt den ganzen Sommer über nicht getan, oder was?
Motorrad fahren? Nee, aber es ist noch mal so kurz, dass es kein richtiger Urlaub ist. Auch nicht mit Übernachten und so, sondern nur so Tagestuern.
Ich war ja im bekloppten Land.
Welches ist denn das bekloppte Land?
Na, Britannien.
Und die U hat dich wieder reingelassen? Also zurück, meine ich?
Ich hab sie ja nicht verlassen.
Noch nicht.
Das muss er vielleicht auch gar nicht. Also das schleppt sich ja jetzt erstmal noch eine Weile. Aber ja, du warst da und wahrscheinlich bei diesem EMF-Camp.
Genau, ich war beim EMF-Camp. Ich war, dachte mir mal...
Electromagnetic Fields hieß das, oder? Also das Field war das Album von Jean-Michel Jarre, ne?
Richtig, und Electromagnetic Field ist halt einfach nur dieses eine Feld, wo halt dieses Camp stattfindet. Und das war ganz aufschlussreich. Also das war wirklich eine der besser organisierten Veranstaltungen. Kann man echt nicht anders sagen.
Ist auch erst das zweite Mal gewesen jetzt, oder? Waren nicht letztes Jahr auch schon eins?
Das war das dritte.
Dritte, okay.
Weil die machen das ja alle zwei Jahre. Was ganz interessant ist schon mal, weil sie halt dadurch eine ganz andere Kontinuität haben in der Organisation dieser Veranstaltungen als zum Beispiel auch der Club oder die Holländer. Weil so alle vier Jahre ist ja schon immer, da passiert ja schon eine Menge so in so einem Leben. Also vor allem in mehrerer Leuteleben gleichzeitig. Also der Grad an Veränderungen, den du dann so allgegenwärtig hast, also Leute, die vorher noch viel freie Zeit hatten, laufen auf einmal mit dreijährigen Kindern durch die Gegend und so.
Du meinst, sie sollten unser Camp alle zwei Jahre machen?
Das ist eine ganz andere Diskussion. Dass das derzeit nicht leistbar ist, glaube ich, wissen wir alle. Oder vielleicht wissen wir es nicht. Auf jeden Fall würden wir da einiges, wenn das CCC Camp alle zwei Jahre stattfinden würde, einiges in Wallung bringen. Allein schon den Zyklus mit den holländischen Camps. Das würde sich natürlich böse beißen.
Dann muss Paul Land auch alle zwei Jahre.
Dann gibt es natürlich den Streit um... Ja, egal. Davon unabhängig. Die machen das auf jeden Fall so. Das ist auch eine etwas anders geprägte Community, die sich sehr viel mehr aus Makerspaces ernährt. Und auch ein bisschen Gaming-Kultur im Hintergrund hat. Das merkt man auch. Ansonsten ist da viel wie bei uns. Weil vieles auch einfach von uns mehr oder weniger so kommt. Also die Idee kam ja aus Holland, aber es gab Datenklos zum Beispiel. Es ist ja mittlerweile eine universelle Idee, sein Netzwerkequipment in alten Klohäuschen unterzubringen. Das ist so eine Idee, die muss nicht nochmal gemacht werden. Die war einfach gut so, wie sie war. Deswegen wird das einfach repliziert. Die hießen auch so. Auch in England. Sie sagten auch Dataloo, aber offiziell war es Datenklo. Das ist schon der Brand, der sich da etabliert hat. Hinzu kam natürlich eine gewisse personelle Überschneidung. Weil wir zum Beispiel im NOG ohnehin ja schon seit langer Zeit eine sehr internationale Gesellschaft haben. Es gibt keinen internationalen, organisatorischen Teil von Open Air-Camps wie das NOG. Weil einfach diese ganze Netzwerk-Crowd da einfach auch zeigt, wie es funktioniert. Erinnert euch, wir hatten auch immer dysfunktionales Netz auf dem Kongress. Also im Wesentlichen dysfunktionales Netz. Zumindest war nie jemand so richtig glücklich, bis die Holländer dazukamen. Und dann später auch die Engländer. Und diese Achse, die spielt auch sozusagen in dieses EMF-Camp mit rein. Also auch da gibt es so NOG-Überschneidungen. Ja, und es war einfach, ich weiß nicht, was soll ich dazu sagen. Es war einfach ein gut organisiertes Camp, was ein paar interessante Schwerpunkte gesetzt hat. Insbesondere hat mich überzeugt, dass die einen sehr produktiven Ansatz gegenüber Software-Erstellungen haben. Also die schreiben einfach welche.
Die trinken nicht Bier, die schreiben Software.
Im Club geschieht das ja auch von Zeit zu Zeit, aber es wird gefühlt immer mehr darüber lamentiert. Aber dass man mal so richtig die Sache in Angriff nimmt, da ist, sagen wir mal, Verbesserungspotenzial. Ich will jetzt hier auch gar nicht groß irgendwas runter machen, sondern ich wollte eigentlich nur betonen, wie gut mir das gefallen hat dort. Also mal ein Beispiel. Es gab da eine Bar. Und diese Bar war dekorationsmäßig wirklich, wirklich schlecht. Also das war eher so holländischer Standard so. Weißes Zelt, Tische fertig. Da geht noch was. Also das ist jetzt nicht so unser Approach. Aber alles andere, wiederum, war Gold. Also sie hatten, glaube ich, eine Selektion von 14 oder 16 Craft-Biersorten. Aus ganz England zusammengekarrt. Also überhaupt kein einziges Mainstream-Bier, glaube ich. Es gab wirklich nur so alle Formen und Farben und Ailes und Stouts. Was England so hergibt, und das ist ja eine Menge. Die dann halt auch aus so korrekten Zapfen kamen. Also davon hatten sie dann irgendwie schon mal so 6 oder 8 Tabs. Und auch der Rest war irgendwie alles schwer in Ordnung. Aber das Beste war, du konntest halt irgendwie, als man natürlich eine elektronische Kasse hat, ich konnte mit meiner Apple Watch, mit Apple Pay, mir auf dem Hackercamp ein Bier kaufen.
Das hab ich total glücklich gemacht.
Zumal ich auch beschlossen hatte, diesmal kein Geld umzuwechseln. Und ich wollte ja sozusagen nur über Apple Pay überleben. Das hab ich ja neulich erzählt, ich hab mir mal diesen Account geklickt. In Deutschland ist das ja so ein bisschen zum Testen, weil da zahlt man immer noch mal so 1,25% noch mal Gebühren, aber da halt nicht, weil das ist ja in England. Das heißt, die Kohle, die ich da in Pfund auf meinem Konto hatte, konnte ich da quasi eins zu eins gebührenfrei ausgeben. Dann wollte ich natürlich immer mit meiner Uhr zahlen. Das ging dann halt ausgerechnet da, auf der Bar in diesem Camp. Fand ich großartig. Aber das Geile ist, nicht so dicht wie die anderen. Auf jeden Fall das Geile war, sie haben dann auch eine eigene Software gehabt, um diese ganze Kasse zu fahren. Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass sie eine Kasse hatten und Katsching und so. Nee, nee, sie hatten ihre ganzen Produkte da eben auch entsprechend einsortiert. Und sie hatten dann aber auch dafür eine Webseite. Also du kannst bar.imfcamp.org eingeben. Vielleicht läuft das sogar jetzt noch, weil ich noch gar nicht ausprobiert bin. Und, glaub ich aber nicht. Und dann hattest du eine Übersicht darüber, was alles noch verfügbar war. Also du konntest dir sozusagen genau anschauen, wie viele Pines noch von welcher Craft-Bier-Sorte quasi verfügbar waren. Weil sie die immer so durchgecycelt haben. Weil sie hatten nicht so viele Tabs wie Sorten. Also haben sie immer so eine Sorte Verbrauche und dann kam irgendwie die nächste dran. Und damit halt noch nicht genug. Nein, es gab natürlich dann dafür auch noch ein API. Also alles, was sozusagen immer in irgendeiner Form von Software abgedeckt ist und öffentliche Information war, hatte auch ein API. Und da man dazu auch noch einen Batch bekam, wie das ja so auf solchen Hacker-Events mittlerweile so üblich ist, und der sogar ziemlich cool war, muss man dazu sagen. Mk3 heißt das Teil, mit Farbdisplay und in Python programmierbar. Ausgelegt wie so ein Game-Controller, also allein schon von der Form her. Du hast links so ein D-Pad und rechts so ein AB-Button und Menü-Button. Und damit kannst du dich dann halt durch entsprechende Menüs auf dem Bildschirm durchhangeln. Und das war halt alles in Python geschrieben. Du hast das Ding bekommen, zusammengesteckt, Batterie ran, also ein Display ran, selber assembled sozusagen die letzten Sachen. Also du musstest es jetzt nicht löten, sondern es war im Prinzip funktionabel. Aber du musstest halt alles, was so Steckerverbindungen hat, selber herstellen. Dann hast du das Ding irgendwie eingeschaltet und dann hat es sich erst mal sofort das voreingestellte Wi-Fi geholt. Also das EMF Camp Wi-Fi hat sich erst mal ein Software-Update runtergeladen und war dann irgendwie betriebsbereit. Sehr cool. Und hat auch einen eigenen App-Store. Also App-Library, wie sie es genannt haben. Das heißt, du kannst sofort auf dem Camp quasi Apps schreiben für diesen Badge in Python, den in diese App-Library einstellen. Und der wurde dann quasi quasi Menü allen anderen Badge-Betreibern auch übermittelt. Was natürlich dann zur Folge hatte, dass alle anfingen, Apps für dieses Teil zu bauen, die dann wiederum die APIs von diesem Camp benutzt haben. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich die Bar-App nicht ausprobiert habe, aber es gab zum Beispiel so eine App für das Fernsteuern eines Blinklichts irgendwie am Ende des Feldes. Und so, womit du dann halt irgendwie so mit der App quasi so on-off so ein Licht schalten konntest. So die Nummer. Also das hat mir alles sehr gut gefallen, weil das auch so eine Art... Also ich finde, dieser Badge ist ein gutes Beispiel, wo es nicht nur so darum geht, so Technologie in die Hände der Leute zu bekommen, wie das jetzt auf dem letzten Camp war mit dem Radio. Ja, jetzt müssen wir alle super nerdy Frequenzanalyse machen und irgendwie alle möglichen Frequenzpatterns auch senden können. Was so Top-Level Hacking ist, gar keine Frage. Aber wie viele Teile wurden davon irgendwie verkauft? Paar Tausend auf dem Kongress? Wie viele Leute hatten sozusagen davon wirklich was auf dem Camp? So, wahrscheinlich die wenigsten. Also es war irgendwie cool, das zu haben und war vielleicht auch cool, das irgendwie in Betrieb zu nehmen. Und vielleicht hat man sich auch mal eine halbe Stunde mit beschäftigt. Aber danach ging es dann halt irgendwie in den Rucksack. Es sei denn, du bist halt total in so embedded Hardware. Ja, die Rocket war ähnlich. Aber um sozusagen da zum Ziel zu kommen und auch wirklich einen Nutzen vor Ort sofort, wenn du das Ding empfängst zu haben, das war da nicht so zu Ende gedacht. Und hier hat man wirklich gemerkt, dass sie nicht nur dieses Ding bauen wollten, sondern sie haben es gebaut. Und sie haben es aber auch soweit weiterentwickelt bekommen und softwaremäßig so ausgestattet, dass es quasi von dem Moment an, wo du es erhalten hast, auf dem Event schon nutzbar war und eigentlich auch über diese zweieinhalb Tage, die der Event ja nur gedauert hat letztlich, immer benutzbarer wurde. Also immer nützlicher wurde auch. Also das ist auch nicht so das universelle Teil, ohne dass du da nicht mehr aus dem Zelt gehen wolltest, aber das hat auf jeden Fall die Richtung ganz klar gezeigt, weil man sich eben auch um Infrastruktur gekümmert hat und bootet und updatet sich und lockt sich ein und hat App-Verzeichnisse etc. Und auch so vom User-Modell her, dass es quasi wie so ein Game-Controller ist, um diesen ganzen Event fernzusteuern. Dafür war das halt auch sehr gut ausgelegt. Also fantastisch.
Na, da steht jetzt aber Microsoft drauf. Das wär natürlich...
Da steht Microsoft drauf. Da stehen auch noch zwei, drei andere Firmen drauf. Texas Instruments.
Das hätte auf dem Camp wahrscheinlich vielen Leuten sauer aufgestoßen.
Aber da war ja auch ein Sticker drauf mit Sponsoren. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das war.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, wie die Sponsorenliste war. Bei dem Badge aber so ganz ohne Sponsoren ging es auch nicht. Microsoft war halt nicht dabei. Ja, mit Microsoft ist das so eine Sache. Also überhaupt das Verhältnis zu Sponsoring ist da auch ein bisschen anders, muss man sagen. Und das hat auch damit zu tun, dass diese Szene einfach nicht so durchpolitisiert ist, wie das eben in Deutschland der Fall ist. Und es liegt dabei auch jetzt nicht um so Leute. Also die werden sicherlich auch alle ihre Erfahrungen mit Microsoft gesammelt haben, mit ihrem Leben, aber das ist jetzt nicht mehr so eine Generation, die quasi eine Dekade lang Microsoft wie den Bälzebub-Popans vor sich hergetragen hat. Sondern, ja, das ist halt irgendein Unternehmen, das irgendwie im Internet Geld verdient. Und auch so Computer gebaut hat, die früher mal ganz populär waren. Ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen der Blick da drauf. Die hatten dann auch so ein Zelt. Da waren dann auch so zwei Microsoft-Fahnen davor. Aber da drin war es wiederum totally un-corporate. Da waren so Tische, wo Leute halt bastelten und hackten. Das war dann irgendwie dann eigentlich auch alles. Also da war jetzt nichts, wo ich jetzt gesagt hätte, so geht gar nicht. Und die haben sich halt auch richtig, es gibt da auch einen Vortrag, wo sie die Story erzählen, wie sie das Ding geplant haben. Also die sind, und auch an diesem Badge kann man das irgendwie sehen. Mit ihrem Zwei-Jahres-Zyklus ist es immer so, die machen jetzt diesen Event, die legen sich jetzt ein Jahr lang aufs Ohr und in einem Jahr fangen sie an, den nächsten Event vorzubereiten. Die haben auch an diesem Badge irgendwie im Prinzip ein Jahr lang gearbeitet, bis der dann halt natürlich immer noch mit heißer Nadel gestrickt, terminlich es dann eben auch tatsächlich auf den Acker geschafft hat. Also, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Electromagnetiefield, schöner Event. Wirklich gelungen. Recht klein, 1.750 Leute, auch absichtlich so limitiert. Also, die erlauben sich sozusagen immer nur ein bestimmtes Wachsum von Event zu Event. Das heißt, sie werden auch das nächste Mal auf diese Zahl wieder nur, keine Ahnung, 20, 30, 40 Prozent mehr Teilnehmer erlauben. Nicht weil nicht vielleicht mehr kommen würden, sondern weil sie sich sozusagen auch organisatorisch entsprechend skalieren wollen. Und das finde ich eigentlich auch einen ganz klugen Ansatz. Es gab sogar eine Kita auf dem EMF-Camp. Also eine richtige, registrierte, angemeldete, offizielle Kita mit registrierter Nummer vom Staat. Wo so ausgebildete Erzieher das Kind angenommen haben und du hast so unterschrieben und dann war das Kind halt da in der Kita. Haben aber dann mit denen so Lego Mindstorms-Kram gemacht und einfach so damit beschäftigt. Aber du warst halt auch, die Brut dann auch richtig los. Du konntest dann also so auch mit 2- und 3-jährigen da hin, also dieses kritische Alter, wo die einfach sehr verhältnismäßig betreuungsintensiv sind, aber noch nicht unbedingt jetzt so in Tune zu bringen sind mit diesem Event. Du konntest also sozusagen auch als Gesamtfamilie da relativ entspannt daran teilnehmen, weil es halt da einfach so eine professionelle Gruppe gab, die da ihr eigenes Zelt hatte und auch Content gemacht hat. Also ganz anderer Ansatz. War korrekter Urlaub.
Zum Thema Microsoft, ich weiß nicht, ich hab mich da schon mal drüber geredet. Ich hab ja versucht, Windows 10 auf dem Raspberry Pi zu installieren. Es scheiterte irgendwie daran, dass man da...
So eine Spezialversion, Windows 10 RT, oder wie heißt das Ding?
Es scheiterte irgendwie daran, dass man bei Microsoft ein Konto anlegen muss.
Konto?
Ja, du musst dann ein Microsoft Konto... Gut, das hab ich dann doch gemacht. Ach so, du kannst aus dem Installer heraus das Konto nicht anlegen, weil irgendwie der Raspberry Pi das nicht kann. Also hab ich das über eine andere Methode gemacht. Und dann hat er es aber irgendwie trotzdem nicht hingekriegt, weil er sich dann der Pi bei dem Konto und so weiter... Weil ich es einfach mal ausprobieren wollte. Ich wollte einfach mal gucken, wie ist denn das, so ein Windows 10 auf einem Raspberry Pi zu fahren. Ich bin nicht schlauer, weil es ist mir nicht gelungen. Also insofern keine Ahnung.
Gut zu wissen.
Da hat sich nicht gelungen.
Da läuft das offiziell auf so Arm.
Ja, da gibt es ein offizielles Pie-Bild für...
Ist das nicht mal RT oder so?
Das ist schon eine Spezialversion. Das ist jetzt nicht das Windows 10, was du dir normal auf dem PC spielst. Aber sie erwecken zumindest den Eindruck, als wäre es halbwegs Feature Complete. Und man könnte das einfach mal ausprobieren und mal machen und mal gucken, wie toll das ist. Ist mir nicht gelungen.
Ich warte schon die ganze Zeit darauf, dass das endlich mal einer von der Großartigkeit von Windows 10 berichtet.
Der Großartigkeit, dass man, wenn man auch so ein Restart macht, gleich mal updated von 9 auf 10 ist auch geil. Ohne Warnung, ohne Abbruchbutton.
Von 9?
Ja, wenn man, was ist denn das? Eine 8, weiß gar nicht mehr.
Ach glaube ich, 9 haben sie übersprungen wegen...
Bodennebel.
Ja, war.
Das übliche. Nee, wir hatten auf der alten Arbeit so einen Monitor, der mal aus Versehen vom Strom genommen wurde. Der hatte halt die alte Version drauf und sollte nicht geupdatet werden. Und als man ihn wieder ansteckte, kam ein Yay, und jetzt mal das Upgrade. Und da stand da ein Touchscreen Monitor.
Da haben sich sehr viele Freunde mitgemacht.
Ja, es war auch sehr schön.
Ich hab mir Windows 10 gleich freiwillig installiert, weil ich gar nicht dieses Upgrade-Drama haben wollte, als ich hier Fallout 4 spielen wollte bzw. sowieso hin und wieder mal eine Windows VM brauche für Tools, die es nicht woanders gibt. Und ja, das tut.
Ich bin mit Windows 7 immer noch ganz zufrieden. Ich auch. Wenn ich denn mal ein Windows brauche.
Aber es gibt auch überhaupt keinen Windows, wo ich jemals begeistert war. Also Tim, du wartest noch da drauf.
Also Windows ist schon ganz okay für mich, oder?
Ja, aber Begeisterung ist auch nochmal anders. Also es ist okay. Man kann damit arbeiten, wenn man muss.
Also nee, das würde ich so nicht sagen. Also zumindest nicht sofort. Weil pro Woche, den ich meinen Windows-Rechner nicht anhabe, braucht er eine Viertelstunde Update-Zeit. Das heißt, hast du den sechs Wochen nicht angemacht, wartest erst mal anderthalb Stunden.
Der Windows 10 update doch beim Ausmachen.
Also wenn ich meinen Rechner ausmachen würde, ich wechsle dann von Windows zurück zum Mac, dann warte ich doch nicht, bis der da fertig ist.
Wenn man so zurückblickt auf das Tal der Tränen, weißt du so NTXP, Windows 2000, Windows Vista, dann ist Windows 7 schon so am Ende dieser Tal der Tränen-Talsole.
Also für mich, muss ich sagen, war Windows 2000 das beste Windows, was ich jemals hatte.
Das hab ich nie benutzt.
Ich auch nicht.
Aber das Windows 7, das ist schon so ein Ende dieser Talsole gewesen. Gut, Windows 8 ist wieder ein anderes Thema.
Also Windows 2000 war doch dieses Windows, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, wo sie diesen NT-Borange und ihr Home-Windows quasi so zusammen, also der Kern untendrunter, war immer noch dieses NT, was halt so ein bisschen mehr solide war.
2000, ja, das war der erste Versuch.
Und das fand ich richtig gut. Also ich kam da von Windows 95, 98 und ME, die absolute Katastrophe von einem Betriebssystem. Und da war Windows 2000 also die Krönung der Schöpfung.
In Sachen Windows. Aber von Windows 95 auf Windows NT 4 war auch, das ist auch deutlich besser. Trotzdem war Windows NT 4 ein totaler Krebs, das überhaupt zu installieren.
Das habe ich ja auch nicht benutzt, davon spreche ich ja nicht.
Ich hab das irgendwann mal installiert und dann nach einem vierten Mal oder so ist mir gelungen die richtige Reihenfolge von Updates und Treibern so einzuspielen, dass es tatsächlich funktioniert hat. Also das ist irgendwie... Nee.
Ich glaube, das habe ich alles schon wieder verdrängt, diese ganzen furchtbaren Dinge.
Ja, sei froh.
Mein Leben ist frei von Windows.
Ich hätte da was, was ich abgeben wollte. Diese Windows-Datenbank.
Ich glaube, das einzige Windows, das ich wirklich mal benutzt habe, war Windows 1.0. Und das taugte damals eigentlich nur zum Starten von Pitchmaker. Das war eigentlich alles, was man damit machen konnte.
Es gibt halt Spiele, die gibt es nicht auf dem Mac. Ansonsten gibt es keinen Grund, ein Windows zu starten.
Ja, noch nicht mal das habe ich gemacht. Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, habe ich schon mal Windows gestartet, um ein Spiel zu starten?
Ist ja auch nicht so kritisch, aber ich habe das tatsächlich zum... Also es gibt ein Musikprogramm, das ich benutze und eigentlich nur Steam für Windows-Spiele gelegentlich mal.
Eben, genau. Das ist bei mir eigentlich die einzige Anwendung.
Damals, als mein erster Mac-Power-PC dann doch mal in die Jahre gekommen ist und ich noch als Schüler bzw. anfangender Student mir noch keinen neuen Mac leisten konnte, da musste ich dann auch mal so ein paar Jahre durch dieses besagte Tal der Tränen und Windows benutzen.
Wollen wir nicht lieber über die Zukunft reden? Nächste Woche ist ja Zukunft.
Wollen wir nicht lieber in der Zukunft über die Vergangenheit reden? Das machen wir dann in zwei Wochen. Oder wolltest du die berühmte Freak-Show-Glasskugel-Sektion hier aufrufen?
Mittlerweile gehört da ja nicht mehr so sehr viel dazu, so wie alles durchgelegt ist. Aber es hilft ja in gewisser Hinsicht, sich auch schon mal mit den Änderungen abzufinden.
Mit dem verschwundenen dreieinhalb Millimeter-Klinken-Port zum Beispiel?
Genau. Damit wird sich nicht abgefunden?
Ja, ich hab drei Kollegen, die haben sich jetzt alle Wochen lang damit rumgeplagt. Kaufe ich mir jetzt das 6S, wenn das neue rauskommt, weil es dann wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen billiger ist vielleicht. Oder kaufe ich mir jetzt schon. Und die haben alle irgendwie also kompletten Unwillen bekundet, sich jetzt diesen Verzicht auf diese Klinkenbuchse sozusagen anzutun. Und natürlich kann man darüber argumentieren, inwieweit das rational gerechtfertigt ist. Aber dieser Reflex ist auf jeden Fall bei mir auch vorhanden.
Man muss ja erstmal abwarten, welches Realitätsverzerrungsfeld von Apple noch kostenlos dazugeliefert wird. Die Storyline sozusagen.
Und vor allem welche Technologie...
Romy ist alles viel besser, wenn der weg ist, was sie dann erzählen werden.
Ja, klar, natürlich. In dieser 2-Stunden-Show wirst du einfach hingewaschen und danach läufst du halt rum wie ein Papagei und sagst halt ja, ah! Die Frage ist nur, welchen Spinnen werden sie da sozusagen entfalten. Und dann hab ich mir so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, was finde ich jetzt eigentlich gerade scheiße an der Situation, wie sie ist. So, in meinem täglichen Umgang mit Kopfhörern, die in das Telefon reingesteckt sind.
Und Headset.
Kabel aufwickeln nervt.
Kabel brechen.
Kabel brechen nervt. Kabel zu lang.
Kopfhörer aufladen nervt auch.
Kabel zu kurz.
Kabel grundsätzlich.
Auch die Kabellänge kriegt Apple aber ganz gut hin, finde ich.
Apple schon, aber wenn man so das Party hat, dann wird es manchmal schwierig.
Meine Kopfhörer, also das sind wieder Probleme, die nicht wirklich da sind. Also ich hatte noch nie ein Kopfhörerkabel an meinem iPhone, wo ich mir dachte, oh Gott, es ist mir zu kurz, oder es ist mir zu lang, ich kann so nicht mehr länger existieren. Weißt du, wo ich die Krise kriegen würde? Ich bin unterwegs mit Musikern und die Batterie von meinem scheiß Bluetooth-Kopfhörer ist alle. Da würde ich die Krise kriegen.
Genau, das ist nämlich schonmal so der erste Punkt. Also es könnte halt unter Umständen noch nerviger sein, keinen Kabel zu haben, weil man dann halt irgendwie auf Akku angewiesen ist. Oder es ist halt nervig, dass der Bluetooth-Kopfhörer so geiler nun auch sein mag für eine bestimmte Anwendung, für die Anwendung, die du in dem Moment gerade im Sinn hast, ja, nicht geeignet ist.
Also ein Problem ist, wenn das Phone jetzt hier ohne diese Buchse rauskommt und ich dann, oder ich hab eh Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, aber wenn alle nur noch Kopfhörer haben, die keine dreieinhalb Millimeter Klinke mehr haben, und du kommst dann aber irgendwie an ein anderes Gerät als das iPhone, was aber dann doch noch klinke ist, aber du hast dann wieder den passenden Kopfhörer, nicht dafür, das wär dann alles ein bisschen bescheuert. Also bisher ist der gemeinsame Nenner ja dreieinhalb Millimeter Klinke. So, wenn Apple das ja auf der einen Seite jetzt aufhört, so, dann passen sich die Leute an und besorgen sich einen Kopfhörer, der das nicht mehr hat, aber es gibt ja noch tausend andere Geräte, wo du vielleicht mal dich reinstöpseln willst.
Vielleicht gibt es aber auch den Passenadapter.
Ja, bestimmt, aber den hast du nicht dabei, wenn du ihn brauchst.
Genau, und deswegen fand ich es ja heute ganz interessant, als die Nachricht herumging von einem neuen Produkt, was leider erst angekündigt ist, weil ich mir so einen Instant-Buy-Reflex hatte, wo ich mich auch gefragt habe, warum gab es denn das bisher eigentlich noch nicht? Griffin hat angekündigt, den iTrip Clip Bluetooth Headphone Adapter.
Der connectet sich mit Bluetooth und dann hat er einen 3,5mm Klinkenstecker.
Und connectet sich zu Engine X in einem Docker-Container, der mit Blockchain gebanagt wird, um über HTTP einen Crypto-Message mit einem Audio-Signal an den API-Server zu schicken, damit du dann über die iCloud und wirklich geht mir, geht doch alles nach Hause.
Aber denn das Teil kombiniert doch die Nachteile von Bluetooth und einem kabelgebundenen Kopfhörer.
Naja, also ich hab drüber nachgedacht, wie denn das jetzt eigentlich für mich wäre. Also mich stört zum Beispiel das Kabel enorm beim Laufen.
Das mach ich ja nicht.
Ja, weil du die ganze Zeit dich irgendwie bei diversen Sportmaßen und sonstigen...
Ich schmeiß mich aber gleich hin.
Du wirst ja nur noch im Rollstuhl durch die Gegend gefahren. Da ist das ja was anderes. Da hat man wahrscheinlich sogar ein Ladegerät eingebaut. So wie Raul hier, das fahrende USB-Ladegerät.
Ja klar, bei Bremsen wird der Akku zurückgeladen.
Naja, aber jetzt kann man sozusagen immer den Kopfhörer der Wahl einfach an dieses Ding ranklippen. Kann auch den Kopfhörer austauschen. Das Gerät ist aber immer mit demselben Adapter gepaart. Das ist auch so was, was mich nervt. Mal eben wechseln mit Bluetooth. Das ist immer so Pair, Unpair, Connected, nicht Connected. Da wirst du ja schon bekloppt, wenn du so einen Bluetooth-Lautsprecher regelmäßig wechselst.
Das Pairing ist das größte Problem an Bluetooth. So ein Kabelpairen ist halt irgendwie einfach. Du steckst es rein, dann ist es gepaart. Was soll die Scheiße?
Aber vielleicht kommen sie ja auch mit Bluetooth 5 auf den Markt.
Oh, und das paert nicht mehr?
Nö, das soll nur irgendwie...
Mit QR-Code?
Das stimmt, das fehlt ja noch am Technologie-Stack.
Keine Ahnung, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass in dem Moment, wo Apple sagt, Bluetooth ist jetzt die Wahl, dass sie unter Umständen auch noch eine kleine nennenswerte Verbesserung im Bereich Handling, Pairing, Wechsel zwischen...
Eine kleine Verbesserung ist da nicht nötig, sondern irgendwie eine große.
Eine große Verbesserung, eine nennenswerte Verbesserung. Die Hoffnung stirbt ja wie immer zuletzt. Und so oder so finde ich diesen kleinen Adapter abgesehen davon, dass er noch nicht mal besonders teuer ist, ich weige den schwer. Ja, ich meine das Ding klippst du halt irgendwie an deinen Hosenbund und dann ist er dran. Dann hast du da irgendwie... Es ist sogar noch ein Mikrofon drin. Das heißt, es macht aus einem normalen Kopfhörer mal eben auch noch ein Headset.
Wie lange hält die Batterie?
Warum gibt es dieses Produkt jetzt erst? Oder gab es schon eins?
Leute im Chat meinen, es gibt es schon eine Weile, auch von anderen Herstellern. Ja, wo denn? Irgendjemand meinte hier von Phillips, der einen Adapter gibt es doch schon seit Jahren. Ich habe hier einen von Phillips in meiner digitalen Müllhalde. Link or didn't happen.
Ja eben, Link or didn't happen. Also ich wäre da sehr...
Aber digitale Müllhalde ist halt genau das, wo das Ding dann auch landet, oder?
Dieser Adapter?
Trip Clip.
Not you trip, sondern I-Trip.
So, hier kommen jetzt andere Hinweise. Mal gucken. Ach nee, das sind aber alles nur so. Was ist das hier? Bluetooth-Empfänger. Bluetooth 3.0, aha.
Aber so billiger.
Top modern.
Und größer.
Ist ja ein riesiger Klotz.
Hält die Batterie aber vielleicht auch für drei Ionen von Jahren.
Viel zu groß. Viel zu groß. Viel zu groß und viel zu hoch.
Na, zum Mitnehmen ist er vielleicht nicht so groß, aber zum an die Apple TV ran.
Ja, aber Bluetooth 3.0. Ich bitte dich. Also, muss schon, also...
Gibt ja ein Nokia BH, der hat Bluetooth.
Ein BH mit Bluetooth. Der denkt sich diese Produktnamen aus bei Nokia.
Gibt es überhaupt Nokia noch?
Machen die jetzt nicht wieder Gummistiefel?
Und Autoreifen.
Bluetooth-Headset.
Ja, die sind aber auch wirklich von ganz damals.
Ja, gut, das sind Headset. Das sind diese peinlichen blau leuchtenden Teile.
Ja, das kommt noch dazu. Warum müssen alle Bluetooth-Produkte eine blaue Leuchtdiode haben? Hätten sie es mal Green Tooth?
Ja, ich meine, eine blaue Leuchtdiode. Hätte ich ja nichts gehabt, wenn sie mal dunkelblau wären und nicht immer dieses grillstrahlende Ich überstrahle alles. Naja. Also sie werden wahrscheinlich so ein iPhone rausbringen, was diesen Port nicht mehr hat. Okay.
Weiß man eigentlich, ob das ein Flüchtigkeitsfehler beim Design war? Oder ob das wirklich eine bewusste Entscheidung war?
Ja, das haben die voll vergessen, so nebenbei.
Also die beste Theorie, die ich dazu gehört hab, war, dass wenn man den Stecker rauslässt, den Port, dann kannst du da noch mal zweiten Lautsprecher einbauen und kannst dann dem iPhone insgesamt relativ viel Umpf geben, was den Sound anbelangt.
Ah, und weil ja eh alle Leute vom Gesicht telefonieren und die dann auch mehr ans Ohr halten.
Das ist auch neu so seit einem Jahr, oder? Dass die sich da so komisch flach vor das Gesicht haben. Ich denke, was machen die da?
Das ist die beste Theorie, die ich gehört hab, warum man sowas überhaupt erwägen würde sollte.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch gut für die Zielgruppe, für die ganzen nervigen Kinder, die da mit in der S-Bahn rumrennen und Uzz Uzz Uzz Musik hören. Kann man ja auch mal so sehen. Und nächstes Jahr kommen sie dann wieder ab.
Wollen wir dann auch einen Bluetooth-Jammer demnächst?
Also lautere Lautsprecher und allein schon laut durch mehr wäre ich auch schwer für zu haben.
Auch für Uzz Uzz Uzz Musik?
Die Klinke, die kann man ja auch wieder an die andere Stelle machen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sag nur, das ist die beste Theorie, die ich gehört hab. Ich sag nicht, dass das der Grund wäre, aber irgendwie alle anderen Erklärungsversuche sind doch noch abstruser, warum man so etwas tun wollte.
Weglassen kann halt nicht mehr kaputt gehen. Wasserdicht sein zum Beispiel ist definitiv ein Argument.
Nein, ist kein Argument, weil es gibt Wasserdichte Headphonejacks.
Entsprechend die auch Apples Qualitätsanforderungen.
Er soll Apple einen bauen.
Fertig. Das ist keine hohe Kunst.
Wie gesagt, es gibt keine glaubwürdigen Erklärungsversuche, den wegzulassen, damit das Ding wasserdicht ist. Das ist Unsinn. Wenn man es wasserdicht bauen will, dann baut man halt einen wasserdichten Headphonejack. Das ist irgendwie... Also Apple sollte das hinkriegen.
Sparen die Platz, wenn sie diesen 3,5 mm Anschluss weglassen? Kannst du die Batterie vielleicht größer machen?
Die müssen ja... Es soll ja auch dünner werden. Das verstehe ich ja auch nicht. Warum immer alles jetzt so unfassbar dünn sein muss.
Deswegen sag ich ja, du sparst Platz. Und den Platz kannst du benutzen, um einen zweiten Lautsprecher einzubauen. Weil damit der halbwegs klingt und Hub hat, brauchst du einen gewissen Resonanzraum da drin, um da den Lautsprecher einzubauen. Wie gesagt, nicht meine Theorie, aber das ist irgendwie die beste, die ich bisher gehört hab.
Aber das, was sie da für aufgeben sozusagen, also alle vorher angefüllten Gründe, ist mir jetzt allerdings auch nicht die 3 Dezibel oder 1 oder 0,5, die ich dann aus diesem extra Lautsprecher habe.
Ja, dir vielleicht nicht, aber wahrscheinlich gibt es bei Apple Leute, die sagen, von unserer Zielgruppe haben, weiß ich nicht, 80% der User noch nie einen Kopfhörer da reingesteckt, also lass uns das Teil aufmachen.
Oder 80% unserer Zielgruppe telefonieren mit dem Telefon vor dem Gesicht jetzt mittlerweile, und deswegen ist Lautsprecher wichtiger.
Aber schon mutig, könnte schon auch ganz schön nach hinten losgehen, oder? Es könnte das Audiogate werden.
Auf jeden Fall, also wenn die das machen, dann wird es das Gate. Ein Gate wird kommen, wir haben es ja schon gesagt.
Man kann es ja nächstes Jahr wieder rückgängig machen.
Also ich bin mir da nicht so sicher. Was wir im Gegensatz zu Apple nicht haben, sind Zahlen und Erkenntnisse, konkrete Erkenntnisse über die Nutzung von ihren Telefonen.
Das sag ich ja, sag ich ja.
Und ich denke, dass sehr, sehr viele Leute benutzen die tatsächlich mit den Kopfhörern, die dabei sind. Und andere kaufen sich dann vielleicht Beats und so ein Kram. Also stylische, funky Musik, Hassnichtdinger, bloß wahrscheinlich, könnte ich mir vorstellen, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das so ist, dass sich das aus den Zahlen ablesen lässt. Dass die Zahl von Bluetooth-Kopfhörern, die jetzt verkauft werden im Verhältnis zu denen, die einfach kabelgebunden sind, so, weißt du...
Dass der Trend abzusehen ist und Apple einsteigt und das beschleunigt.
Genau, dass der Trend einfach so klar ist, dass das so abgeht, weil die jetzt ihre kritische Masse überschritten haben an Qualität. Im Sinne von Akku hält lange noch, ist einfach genug zu benutzen, hat eine korrekte Qualität, kommt mit so sonstigen Features wie Noise Cancellation, Pipapo und so. Also du willst auf einmal in diese High-End-Klasse rein, um einfach ganz anderes Hörerlebnis zu haben. Und dann entscheiden sich die, die große Mehrheit entscheidet sich einfach dann auch gleich für Bluetooth, weil Kabel weg ist dann auch einfach nochmal eine Qualität. Sind ja jetzt nicht alles solche so oldschool Honschoes wie ich, die sagen, hier HD 25 und was anderes kommt mir nicht auf die Ohren. Ja, da bin ich halt eine Minderheit und wie immer nicht der Trend.
Es ist sowieso extremer noch, weil zumindest bis zu einer gewissen Qualität ist so ein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer besser als ein rein analoger, weil du hast da sowieso digitale Signalverarbeitung drin. Also kannst du auch die schrottige Kennlinie von deinen Wandlern wegrechnen und dann klingt es einfach mal besser, als wenn du versuchst irgendwie für billig Geld halbwegs brauchbare Wandler da einzubauen. Es könnte das noch beschleunigen, dass du halt einfach auch kaum Hersteller hast, die ordentliche Lautsprecher bauen können, aber es gibt halt jede Menge Silizium, die dir halt den Scheiß wegrechnen.
Genau, das heißt, wenn du jetzt sagst, sie ist ok, 80% unserer Käufer benutzen die mitgelieferten Headphones und jetzt liefern sie halt, wissen wir noch nicht, Bluetooth-Headsets mit? Warum nicht?
Ich glaube, die liefern was mit Lightning mit.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich meine, alleine schon dieser Fakt, dass sozusagen sie ihre gesamten Milliarden von weißen iPhone-Kopfhörersets einfach Mülltonnereif jetzt selber machen. Also so dieses Plaste-Weckwerf-Phänomen, ich weiß nicht, ich finde das so entsinnlos. Trotz alledem.
Ein Adapter ist wahrscheinlich dabei, da gibt es ja auch schon die passenden Fotos, die ausreichen. Also es gibt halt einen Adapter, dann kannst du es halt in den Lightning-Port reinstecken, für die Leute, die da halt analog ran wollen.
Und sich ihren Lightning-Port zerbröseln wollen, weil da so ein Dödel raus...
Den gibt es nur extra, da bin ich mir relativ sicher. Der ist nicht dabei.
Aber wenn jetzt mal ein Markt jetzt hier entsteht, wie zum Beispiel mit diesem iTrip-Clip, der definitiv jetzt gestaltungsmäßig und vielleicht auch vom Produktnamen her noch mal ein bisschen... Oh Gott, da würden mir noch ein paar andere pornoeske Kommentare zu einfallen. Aber das Ding in noch schicker... Ich meine, wenn Griffin da unterwegs ist, dann wird wahrscheinlich Belkin nicht lange auf sich warten lassen und irgendwelche anderen Hersteller auch, weil warum auch nicht, also warum nicht, in so ein Teil, was nochmal entkoppelt ist? Warum nicht?
Ich will keinen Bluetooth laufen lassen. Ich hab nie Bluetooth an. Ich brauch null Bluetooth sozusagen in meinem Leben und ich will...
Dann hol dir auch keine Apple Watch.
Du hast Bluetooth nicht an?
Weil ich brauch's nicht.
Achso, na okay, schon.
Also ich hab keine Geräte, die Bluetooth sprechen und ich leg da auch... Also ich hab kein Bedürfnis danach. Aber ich bin da wahrscheinlich auch die alte grauhaarige Minderheit.
Also ich glaube, dass die Kopfhörer, denen sie mitliefern, wahrscheinlich auch eher Lightning als Bluetooth ist. Weil du machst halt einen anderen Stecker ran und fertig. Also in so ein bisschen Lightning kriegst du glaube ich einen Wandler rein. Weil Strom kriegst du vom Handy, also vom iPhone. Und dann tut es. Bluetooth ist schon ein bisschen mehr Technik.
Aber dann kannst du halt nicht dein Gerät laden und Kopfhörer aufhaben.
Vielleicht hat es wie die Apple Watch Induktionsladung.
Du kannst beim iPad Pro ja auch nicht das Gerät laden und den Stift gleichzeitig laden.
Aber der Stift braucht nur 5 Sekunden. Meine Musik dauert länger.
Ich frage mich nur, ob man über diese Induktionsladung denselben Strom rüberkriegt, wie man ihn jetzt braucht für Speed-Loading. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Weil ich denke, eines der neuen Ninjas von dem iPhone 7 wird sicherlich sein, dass es jetzt auch diese Schnellladefunktion hat. Mit anderen Worten, zwei...
2 Ampere.
Zwei Teslas pro Minute?
Zwei Ampere. Wie ist die Speck? Ich hab überhaupt keine Lust mehr über Strom-Einheiten zu reden, weil ich mich letztens so vertan habe. Mit mir war das ja. Genau, im Club irgendwie. Kannst du bitte übernehmen? Ich rede einfach.
War das jetzt das Bluetooth?
Warst du das oder war ich das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was hier gerade passiert ist.
War das auch im Stream oder nur bei uns?
Das war auch im Stream. Ich frag mich nur gerade, wo das herkommt. Hat dir gerade irgendeine bekloppte Webseite angefangen, wie ihr sein Werbevideo automatisch starten könnt?
Also die Musik war jetzt nicht länger als 5 Sekunden.
Ich frag mich nur gerade, wer jetzt sowas gemacht hat.
Wer gerade sich auf dein Bluetooth-Audio-Kanal gehackt hat.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, jetzt dieses OS, was einem noch nicht mal sagen kann, wo Audio herkommt.
Ich mach das der Safari anzwischen schön mit dem Lautsprecher-Symbol in den Taps.
Da steht nix, also kommt es nicht von Safari.
Dann kommt es nicht von Safari. Vielleicht hat hier jemand... Im Chat war es auch keiner.
Ist auch egal.
Das war diese komische Soma-App, aber die hatte ich doch auf leise gestellt.
Was soll's? Na ja, du kannst natürlich das Phone auf deinem Induktions-Dingens auf dem Nachttisch über Nacht langsam laden. Das ist egal, ob es sechs Stunden braucht oder nicht. Und wenn du es zwischendurch mal schnell laden willst, dann kannst du halt gerade keine Musik hören.
Aber eigentlich ist das Schnellladen doch genau dann interessant, wenn ich... Also für mich würde ich denken, ich sitze irgendwie an meinem Büro-Arbeitsplatz, ich brauche das andauernd, will es aber gleichzeitig laden. Das heißt, ich leg's immer auf die Lade-Pad, dann benutze ich's wieder und dann leg ich's wieder drauf. Das heißt, ich spar mir jedes Mal dieses Kabel an und abstecken, wenn mich das stören würde. Aber nachts, da ist mir doch egal, ob ich's auf eine Fläche lege oder ob ich jetzt einmal ein Kabel anschließe, dann pennen gehe und nächsten Morgen ist fertig. Also eigentlich ist das doch nur, wenn ich das viel brauche und ohne Kabel haben will. Dann ist dieses Pad-Laden doch praktisch.
Apple wird sicherlich unsere alle Probleme auch wieder...
Unsere nicht vorhandenen...
Unsere nicht vorhandenen Probleme wunderbar gelöst bekommen.
Ich glaube, Apple bringt da dieses Pad-Laden nicht. Ist das denn so spannend? Ich weiß nicht. Kennt jemand, der sowas benutzt, der es voll toll findet?
Das Problem ist, dass dieses... Wie nennt man denn das eigentlich korrekt? Dieses Laden?
Induktiv.
Ist das so der offizielle Term, mit dem das verkauft wird?
Nein, da ist die Technologie dahinter.
Bleiben wir dabei. Induktive Ladetechnik hat ja eigentlich keine wirklichen Vorteile, weil du brauchst ja immer noch ein Kabel.
Dicht fest am Telefon.
Aber du kannst dein Gerät wasserdicht machen.
Ein Kollege von mir, der benutzt das mit seinem Android und der hat da so ein Art Stand-Ding, da packt er das drauf und dann liegt das da. So wie das Phone sowieso auf dem Tisch liegt, wenn du irgendwie im Büro Zeug machst. Hier, liegt auf dem Tisch. Du kannst es auch irgendwo drauf packen, wo irgendwie Induktion drunter ist. Aber ohne, dass du immer einen Kabelrand gnubbeln musst.
Gab's nicht sogar bei IKEA, serienmäßig schon so Tische mit Ladeflächen und so.
Die haben das auf jeden Fall auch in das Büchlein mit aufgenommen.
Es gibt da Nachtischlampen und allensdings, soweit ich weiß, gibt es aber mehrere konkurrierende Standards für induktives Laden. Was die Sache nicht so schön macht. Und du kannst dann von IKEA auch nochmal so ein Cover zum Laden für iPhone kaufen. Das sieht aber scheiße aus und ist teuer. Also es bringt alles nicht so richtig.
So läuft's.
Apropos IKEA. Oder lieber kein Themenwechsel?
Bitte?
Ich war im IKEA-Museum.
Was?
In Almhult.
Du warst ja auch im Urlaub. Du hast ja noch gar nicht berichtet.
Ist das jetzt hier irgendwie so?
Ich wollte das auch mal machen. Ich war noch nie in Schweden. Also diese ganzen Merkwürdigkeiten, über die man da sprechen kann, das machen wir nächstes Mal, wenn Clemens wieder dabei ist. Der muss mir dann Rede und Antwort stehen.
Nächstes Mal reden wir ja irgendwie über die Keynote.
Ja, dann ist er nächstes Mal nicht dabei.
Dann reden wir über die Vergangenheit.
Dann halt über nächstes Mal. Das tut ja auch nichts. Aber IKEA-Museum kann man sich sparen.
Nee, es hat mich nicht dahin verschlagen.
Ganz ehrlich kann man sich sparen. Wirklich? Ja, es ist halt eine große Werbeveranstaltung für Ingmar Kamprad und IKEA im Besonderen im Allgemeinen. Ich finde es frech, dass sie dafür Eintritt nehmen, wenn man dann irgendwie...
Wenn man auch für uns sonst zu Kia gehen könnte.
Da auch noch Eintritt zu nehmen, wenn man am Ende sowieso noch mal ein paar Quaternien und irgendwie einen Esslöffel Salatschüssel rausgeht.
Naja, sie haben noch so einen Museums-Shop, aber da gibt es eigentlich irgendwie auch nur den Kram, den du irgendwie da im Wühltisch, in der Wühltischhalle von IKEA kriegst. Also, mich hat, ja... Also der Anfang der Ausstellung, wo es wirklich ganz, ganz früh anfängt, so, die ist schon ganz nett, aber...
Da sieht man dann, wie er als kleines Kind mit Holzspielzeug schon tolle Möbel gebaut hat, oder was?
Aber sag mal, von diesem I Trip Clip gibt es doch das Gegenteil, dass ich einen Audio-Ausgang mit Bluetooth auf meinen Bluetooth-Kopfhörer kriege?
Was gibt's?
Hier darf man nicht Luft rauskannnen.
Ein Audio-Ausgang, ein Light-Out.
Die verbale Blutgrätsche hier.
Deine Aufmerksamkeitsspanne war fertig. Das ist auch das Einzige.
Was auch okay ist, weil mehr kommt nicht. Nein, es lohnt sich nicht. Also wer da mal ist und das unbedingt sehen will, okay, aber man muss da nicht hinfahren, um sich das anzugucken.
Ich dachte, er war fertig.
Ja, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ist das alles, was du nicht hier im Museum erzählen kannst?
Dass es sich nicht lohnt? Ja, genau. Deswegen lohnt es sich ja nicht.
Aber wait a minute. Und sonst in Schweden, was gab es noch so?
Älche.
Hast du die süßen Suppen probiert? Das war so mein Highlight in Schweden. Die kannte ich vorher nicht. In Schweden gibt es irgendwie Blaubeersuppe und so Früchtesuppen. So wie bei uns im Nudelsuppen.
Wusstest du, wie machen sie sich auch Blaubären auf ihren roten Fisch, den sie da essen?
Den hab ich auch nicht gekriegt irgendwie.
Aber das schmeckt wirklich. Das fand ich ziemlich geil. Da gab es irgendwie so süße Suppen. Und gerade wenn man beim Wandern ist, will man ja nur leichtes Zeug dabei haben.
Das war nur irgendwie Clemens so, wo bist denn gerade? Ah ja, dann geh mal in den und den Laden und ess was, das heißt Budapest. Na gut, bin da rein. Ich hätte gern Budapest. Das ist so, ich weiß nicht, ob es noch Kuchen ist oder schon nur Nachtisch. Das ist so, man muss sich vorstellen, so eine Rolle, die ist außen Baiser, da drin dann Sahne. Und in der Sahne noch mal Nüsse und Früchte. So ganz ohne, ist unglaublich lecker, aber du isst dieses Teil und denkst dir, okay, jetzt hab ich das Mittagessen eigentlich auch schon hinter mich gebracht. Doch sehr lecker, irgendwie.
Das muss ich mir dann fürs nächste Jahr aufheben.
Ja, mach das.
Ich weiß nur, dass es da auch irgendwie Elchdöner gibt.
Naja, wir waren in so einem Elchpark. Naja, Park ist auch übertrieben. Naja, sie hatten halt so ein paar Freigehege, da waren so Elche drin, da konnte man die aus der Nähe angucken und dann haben sie einem so Birkenzweige gegeben, dass man die da füttern kann, dass die auch rankommen und man hat was von dem Elch. Und äh, dann gab's in der angeschlossenen Gastronomie gab's einen Elchburger. Ja, das war, nee, die hatten dann schon zu. Und wie war der Burger? Die hatten dann schon zu. Was, du hast nicht? Nein, leider nicht.
So lange gesucht, bis?
Den Elchburger hab ich in Amiland gegessen, damals, nachdem wir auf dem Vulkan waren, aber, ähm, nee dort nicht. Aber das kann man ja alles nochmal machen. Die schlimmsten Kritiker der Elche sind meistens selber welche.
Ihr kennt das tatsächlich. Wer gibt's nicht zu berichten aus links? Hatten wir nicht vorhin irgendwas mit Fahrstühlen? Ich hatte eine Fahrstuhl-Situation.
Aber die Uhr ist doch noch ganz.
Wir haben uns nur Fahrstühle unterhalten. Nicht hart, ja.
Ich finde ja Fahrstühle sind ja generell, ich finde Fahrstühle sind generell so ein besonderes Ding in unserer Zivilisation. Also allein erst mal so ihre pure Existenz in unserem Kulturraum. Du hast so unfassbar hohe Orte, also so. Türme, Hochhäuser und so. Und dann hat man halt angefangen, sich ein Gerät zu bauen, was einem sozusagen auch noch das Klettern abnimmt. Das finde ich ja irgendwie geil. Also so ein Fahrstuhl an sich ist irgendwie doch ein ganz interessanter Teil unserer Technikwelt. Und mich haben Fahrstuhl auch immer schon fasziniert und das ist so eins meiner letzten. Und wahrscheinlich wird es auch unerfüllt bleiben, aber ich hatte immer vor, so als Programmierer irgendwann auch noch mal einen Fahrstuhl-Algorithmus zu programmieren. Das hat mir irgendwie gereizt, aber irgendwie habe ich den Arsch hochbekommen.
Hast du es im Tower gespielt? Das wäre vielleicht ein Spiel für dich gewesen, da geht es nämlich auch um...
Sim-Tower.
Sim-Tower, also wie SimCity, nur du baust einen Turm und da kommen immer Leute zur Geschäftszeit, also musst du einen Mix aus Büro, Apartment und so weiter bauen in dem Turm und dann kommen zu den verschiedensten Zeiten verschiedene Leute in den Turm und du musst eine Fahrstühle halt auch so designen, dass es da nicht große Wartezeiten gibt und so weiter und so fort. Hat mir früher auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
SimTower.
Ja, ist ein recht altes Spiel, aber...
Also ich weiß nicht, ich hab ja selten Albträume, aber wenn ich mal welche hab, dann nur mit Fahrstühlen. Ich weiß nicht wieso. Also nicht, dass ich Angst vor Fahrstühlen hätte, aber wenn ich Albträume hab, dann ist immer ein Fahrstuhl involviert.
Deswegen das mit der Uhr, du warst einfach in Panik. Nee, aber Timmy, bei...
Weil du Angst hast, da abzustürzen?
Also wenn ich Schiss hab mit dem Fahrstuhl, dann eher, dass ich stecken bleibe. Besonders, wenn der so klein ist, dass ich mich kaum umdrehen kann.
Ja, diese Ort, diese Neubau, oder keine Ahnung, aus welcher Zeit die kommen. So ein bestimmter Gebäudetypen, da passt er zu zweit schon kaum rein. Da denk ich mir auch jedes Mal, bitte nicht stecken bleiben.
Dennis, vor zwei Tagen, was war da? In Mitte, du hast was?
Stromausfall.
Genau, es gab Stromausfall in Mitte. Im Club sind alle Server einmal aus und wieder eingeschaltet worden.
Ich saß zu Hause, meine Anlage machte Klick Klick, weil die hat irgendwie so ein Relais drin, wenn man sie einschaltet, das ist irgendwie Sony. Du hast ja die gleiche, du kennst das. Und die machte Klick Klick, das Licht ging kurz an und aus. Der Movie, den ich gerade auf meinem Mac Pro guckte, der lief weiter, mein Router in der Küche lief weiter. Da dachte ich, hm, war das so ein 1-Sekunden-Stromausfall? Hab einen Rechner im Club irgendwie angepinkt? Kein Dings, eine Minute gewartet, eingeloggt, alles klar. Abtime eine Minute. Also der hat dann auch gebootet, genau zu der Zeit. Und dann wusste ich, alles klar.
Ich dachte, du sitzt da eben.
Nee, nee, nee, ich war nicht vor Ort. Ich hab das gleich gecheckt.
Ich war im Fahrstuhl.
Genau, dann?
Ja, ich war zu einem sehr interessanten Zeitpunkt im Fahrstuhl. Und der Fahrstuhl hat dann auch was sehr Interessantes getan. Also ich war in meinem Fahrstuhl. Also ich bin eingestiegen.
Die Tür ging zu.
Und der Stromausfall war vermutlich, das ist jetzt meine These, ungefähr so 20% bevor die Tür geschlossen war.
Also die Tür schloss sich 80% zu.
80% zu, genau. 80% zu. Und dann gab es wohl irgendwie diesen Stromausfall. Das ist jetzt meine Vermutung. Denn die Tür ruckelte irgendwie kurz, also stoppte, lief dann aber auch sofort wieder weiter. Also als ich irgendwie schaute, was geht hier ab, schloss sie sich und da ich dem Fahrschluss zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon gesagt hatte, dass ich nach oben möchte, fuhr er auch nach oben. Aber sehr langsam. Und zwar sehr langsam. Also wirklich so ein, zwei Zentimeter pro Sekunde langsam. Ich fuhr irgendwie so eine halbe Stockwerke nach oben.
Was denn hier los?
Weil ich hatte das jetzt mit dem Stromausfall selber nicht mitbekommen. Ich hab nur mitbekommen, was macht jetzt dieser Fahrstuhl? Ich guck aufs Display, da stand JU.
Jans unten.
Keine Ahnung, was die junge Union damit zu tun hat. Weiß ich nicht. Falls irgendjemand eine Ahnung hat, warum der Fahrstuhl in dem Moment JU angezeigt hat, mir würde da gar nichts zu einfallen. Weil er war offensichtlich in so einem Schutzmodus. Naja, er blieb dann nach einer Weile stehen. Also er fuhr sehr langsam nach oben, weil das war das, was ich ihm gesagt hab. Dann blieb er kurz stehen. Und dann fuhr er mit der selben Geschwindigkeit wieder nach unten, ins Erdgeschoss, also so sehr langsam ins Erdgeschoss und machte die Tür wieder auf.
Und du bist sicher, dass das zu dem Stromausfall-Zeitpunkt war?
Ziemlich, weil er sich dann unten ankam und Tür aufmachte, standen irgendwie Nachbarn vor der Tür, vor dem Fahrstuhl und erzählten mir was, dass ja eben gerade auf der Straße kurz die Laterne ausgegangen sei.
Justierfahrt wird im Chat behauptet.
Das heißt, das Ding ist irgendwie so resettet worden und musste erstmal sich irgendwie einnorden auf...
Und du standest halt schon drin, wovon die eigentlich gar nicht ausging. Das Ding hat sich jetzt also auf 100 Kilo Mehrgewicht justiert und das jetzt jedes Mal...
Aber das passt ja, also als wir vorhin über Fahrstühle, ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir da drüber gesprochen haben, aber ich glaube, da haben wir darüber nachgedacht, wie die überhaupt ein- und ausgebaut werden, wenn es mal Probleme gibt. Aber der Fahrstuhl bei meinem Proberaumgebäude, also nicht, dass das Gebäude meins wäre, aber da, wo der Proberaum ist, da ist noch so ein alter Fabrik-Lastenaufzug ohne Tür in der Kabine.
Man sieht die Wände, die an dir vorbeischauen.
Man sieht die Wand vorbeiskrollen, genau. Du weißt, dass es nicht erlaubt ist, ne?
Für normales Personal wie dich. Dürfte der nicht zugänglich sein.
Wie auch immer, der hat Lichtschranken. Also sobald der sich bewegenden Wand, also der vorbeiskrollenden Wand, dich näher ist, dann bleibt er halt stehen. Aber der hat jetzt nicht so vielleicht den allerbesten Algorithmus. Der ist halt auch von 1900 also ganz alt. Und was der dann macht, wenn du an diese Lichtschranke kommst, ist manchmal folgendes, also der bleibt dann halt stehen. Dann muss man wieder den Schlüssel reinstecken und sagen, okay, ich bin wieder da und wir fahren jetzt weiter. Lichtschranke ist geklärt sozusagen von dem Deppen, der sich da reingestellt hat. Und dann meistens fährt man halt hoch oder runter natürlich. Oder beim Runterfahren ist es besonders spannend, weil dann hat er nämlich seine Justierung auch vergessen. Und was dann passiert ist, er fährt normal runter ins Erdgeschoss, aber er weiß nicht genau, wo er anhält. Und hält dann auf halber Höhe zu diesem Hofausgang. Und man kriegt die Tür nicht auf. Die ist halt gelockt sozusagen. Die Türen gehen immer nur auf, wenn du genau auf der Stockwerkhöhe bist. Und irgendwie dachte ich mir so, was machen wir jetzt so? Naja, vielleicht muss er sich jetzt irgendwie einladen, drücken wir mal Keller und gucken mal, ob wir auf irgendeinem Stockwerk richtig rauskommen. Und Keller, da geht es ja nicht tiefer. Drücken wir auf Keller und er fährt halt runter und rollt an dieser Tür vorbei. Und in dem Moment merkst du, wie der einfach in den Gleitflug übergeht. Also das ist kein Fallen, weil die Drahtseile und so weiter, das geht ja trotzdem über Rollen und so weiter. Da ist jetzt nicht genug, was auch immer, weil er plumpst mehr oder weniger auf die Puffer dann unten. Das ist auch nicht viel, aber da hast du das Gefühl, ich geh jetzt mal kurz in die Knie, weil ich weiß nicht, wie sich das jetzt gleich anfühlt, wenn die Kabine da unten aufsetzt. Und das ist so ein kleiner Nervenkitzel beim ersten Mal gewesen, wenn man es dann mal schon gemacht hat, kann man sich darauf einstellen, aber davon hatte ich Albträume. Dieses Gefühl, der Fahrstuhl schaltet jetzt auf Durchzug und fällt sozusagen runter, in Anführungsstrichen. Was man bei dem Fahrstuhl dann machen muss, ist einmal ins oberste Geschoss fahren und dann hat er sich wieder eingesüngt und weiß, wo er ist sozusagen und hält wieder genau richtig an den Türen. Aber das ist wirklich eigentlich die Ausnahme, weil ich hab ja mal eins der wenigen UDK-Projekte, was ich ja mal gemacht hab, hier bei meinem Kunststudium, hab ich bestimmt auch schon mal erzählt, hier hab ich mich ja mit Fahrstühlen beschäftigt, weil ich ja die Fahrstuhlstille durchbrechen wollte. Man kennt das, man unterhält sich gerade, dann ist das schon jemand im Fahrstuhl und dann sind alle ganz still und warten bis man dann aussteigt wieder und das Gespräch fortzusetzen. Naja, das wollte ich halt so irgendwie interaktiv aufbrechen und hab mich dann auch damit beschäftigt, wie man eigentlich Fahrstühle, also wie tief kann man da als Hans Wurst irgendwie mit diesen Fahrstühlen spielen. Und es stellte sich heraus, dass halt diese Stockwerkswahl und dieses ganze Panier, was da drin ist, so dieser Controller, im Prinzip kannst du damit machen, was du willst, und dann den Arduino da anschließen und so weiter, weil die ganzen Sicherheitsfeatures, die sind halt außerhalb der Kabine. Also da gibt's nochmal obendrauf meistens halt nochmal den eigentlichen Fahrtcontroller. Zumindest war das, wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung hab. Und wenn man sich auch noch ein bisschen durchliest, was sozusagen eigentlich seit den letzten 70 Jahren an Sicherheitstechnik alles an diesen Fahrstuhlkabinen ist. Also Alpträume sind da natürlich aber eigentlich komplett unberechtigt, weil da gibt's Backup-Seile, die automatischen Bremsen und alles mögliche. Also es kann eigentlich wirklich in so einem Fahrstuhl heutzutage nichts passieren, es sei denn... Es sei denn, es ist Internet of Things, da gab's ja hier dieses tolle Bild, wo habt ihr das gesehen? Irgendwie so jemand auf die glorreiche Idee kam, so ein Touch-Interface für den Fahrstuhl zu machen. Und dann kam so ein Rollstuhlfahrer und wollte halt mit dem Rollstuhl runter und twitterte das Bild von diesem Touchscreen, wo drauf stand, No database found. Und er nur twitterte, wer auch immer das war, könnt ihr mal bitte das Backup einspielen, ich möchte nach Hause. Kann natürlich alles passieren, aber sicherheitstechnisch kann eigentlich nicht viel passieren, außer wenn man, wie bei Artcom, hatten wir auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, so ein Patanoster halt noch hat, wo sich schon diverse Menschen relativ schwer verletzt haben da in dem Gebäude. Also ich hab da zweimal Blutspuren auf den... Ja, das Problem ist halt, Leute, es steht explizit dran, keine sperrigen Gegenstände in diesem Patanoster mitnehmen. Einmal war es der Paketbote, der mit seiner Sackkarre da rein ist, weil er nicht in den Fahrstuhl warten wollte, die sich dann im Stockwerk verkantet hat und die Kabine und scheinbar ihn zu teilen geschreddert hat. Einmal war es eine ältere Frau, die zur Augenklinik im ersten Geschoss fahren wollte und wohl auch eher unsanft... Und so, ne? Also...
Und nicht so richtig gesehen hat, was sie tut.
Ja, es stehen wirklich große Schilder, auch Patienten der Augenklinik, genau das war das.
Das hat ja einen Grund, warum sie inzwischen komplett abgeschafft haben, ne?
Im Görlitzer Rathaus auch noch. Und da sind wir auch mal drum rumgefahren.
Also in der Jörgstraße in dem Rathaus gab es das früher auch. Ich kann mich nur erinnern, hab das als Kind auch mal benutzt, aber den haben die irgendwann weggemacht.
Also in Görlitz gibt es den glaube ich nach wie vor. Es war natürlich ganz spannend, wenn man ein Kind war, da mal mitzufahren und mal gucken, was passiert, wenn man oben bleibt.
Aber vom Pater Nostra bei Artkomm hatte ich auch viele Albträume. Sie waren eigentlich unberechtigt, mir ist nie irgendwas passiert. Aber mein Albtraum war da immer, dass ich einsteigen wollte, aber es fährt zu schnell. Und ich hab einfach diese Panik so, wenn ich es jetzt verpasse, dass ich da auch irgendwie gleich gegen die Kante und Matsch oder beim Aussteigen, dass es zu schnell fährt und ich nicht rauskomme.
Also mein erster Albtraum war, dass ich irgendwie in einem Hochhaus unten in den Fahrstuhl bin, nach oben gefahren. Und oben geht der Fahrstuhl auf und das Gebäude ist noch nicht fertig gebaut. Ich steh dann auf so einem Stahlträger mitten im Nichts, dreh mich um, hinter mir macht der Aufzug die Tür zu und fährt runter. Aber da ist natürlich auch kein Bedienfeld, um den Aufzug wieder zu holen. Solche Sachen, das ist natürlich komplett abstrus.
Eigentlich, was wir jetzt noch als Frage hatten vor der Sendung, war, wie eben so eine Kabine da eingebaut wird. Also wird sozusagen erst der Schacht gebaut und dann wird die im Schacht zusammengebaut. Oder wird der Schacht gebaut und solange der Deckel noch nicht drauf ist, wird die mit dem Kran reingehievt und dann, wenn da das Dach drauf ist...
Das ist ja so ein holes Gestell, dann kommen da so ein paar Seitenwände rein und fertig, oder?
Aber das Ding ist zum Beispiel, in der Backfabrik, kleinen Moment, der Fahrstuhl ist immer kaputt. Also die servicen den wirklich alle zwei Wochen. Und die ganze Zeit denken wir uns so, hey, tausch doch diese Kabine aus. Wenn diese Türen da so scheiße sind, warum wechselt ihr nicht aus? Also es kann doch nicht sein, dass ihr alle zwei Wochen für ein Fahrteil diesen Fahrstuhl ausmachen müsst. Aber wenn wir halt die Kabine tauschen würdest wollen, zerlegst du es dann im Schacht oder wie auch immer, ne?
Also im S-Bahnhof Wedding machen sie gerade den Fahrstuhl neu. Und da haben sie nicht das Dach abgemacht. Da haben sie die alte Kabine irgendwie rausgeholt. Und ich nehme mal an, dass sie die neue Kabine auch irgendwie da wieder reinkriegen, ohne dass sie oben das Dach abnehmen. Also das muss irgendwie gehen.
Ich würde es auch vermuten. Dass sie den halt so reinbauen. Vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwelche YouTube-Videos oder so.
Übrigens, Timme, wenn du ein Fahrstuhl-Algorithmus programmieren willst, ist ja noch nicht so, dass es nur bei Fahrstuhlen gebraucht wird, sondern bei ZFS. Da gibt es den sogenannten Elevator-Algorithm. Der sorgt dafür, dass, wenn die Daten auf noch hier im Spinning Rust geschrieben werden, dass der Kopf immer nur schön hin und her fährt und die Daten werden so sortiert, dass der Kopf nur einmal von ganz außen nach ganz innen fährt und wieder zurück. Das heißt, die Daten werden vorsortiert. Das ist der Elevator-Algorithm. Dass der Kopf immer nur einmal von einem Ende zum anderen fährt und alle Daten genau so geschrieben werden und dann wieder zurück, dass er nicht so randommäßig hin und her fährt, sondern dass alles schon für eine Bewegung durchsortiert wird.
Über alle Spuren.
Das heißt, er muss dann schon mal anhalten, da wo die Daten hinwollen, aber er fährt jetzt nicht irgendwie zurück, sondern er macht eine Wege zum Rand und dann wieder zurück und dann das geht immer so die ganze Zeit so Elevator-mäßig hin und her.
Ich meine, diese Optimierung ist natürlich insofern sehr knifflig, als dass man ja einerseits, also es gibt ja unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, seinen Fahrtwunsch anzuzeigen. Der Klassiker ist, du steigst halt ein und fängst dann irgendwie an, an Knöpfe zu drücken. Was ich jetzt in jüngster Zeit häufiger gesehen habe, sind so Fahrstühle, wo du halt sagen musst, wo du hin willst.
Bevor du im Fahrstuhl bist.
Das heißt, du hast quasi deine Ziel...
Also du musst drücken, hoch oder runter, ne?
Na hoch oder runter ist so klassisch, das ist aber mal so das Minimum an Auswahl. So, dass der Fahrstuhl schon mal sagen kann, na du willst ja hoch, dann brauche ich beim Runterfahren nicht anhalten. So, damit man im Wesentlichen immer nur so von unten nach oben fährt. Das ist schon mal eine ganz interessante Optimierung. Die andere Optimierung ist halt, dass du halt von vorne rein sagst, ich will halt dahin. Wobei, dass ja dann auch mehrere Leute im Prinzip drücken können, müssen so, kann man sich dann irgendwie verbessern, kann man irgendwie clear machen. Also ich weiß nicht so genau, wie gut das funktioniert, aber es gibt zumindest Fahrstühle, die dann im Fahrstuhl selber gar keine Auswahlmöglichkeit mehr bieten.
Also wenn man erst mal drin steht und man denkt sich um, dann hat man es schon zu spät, dann muss man einmal das mitmachen.
Genau, aber da sind wir wieder in dieser Apple-Situation, vielleicht machen das halt die meisten Leute auch nicht. Und am Ende geht es doch gut. Aber kann auch sein, dass das so ein sterbener Spahn ist und dass sie das nur für eine tolle Idee gehalten haben, als die ganzen Elevator-Nerds noch alleine mit ihrem Kot waren. Und dass es dann sozusagen in real life nicht funktioniert hat. Ich vermute mal, diese Optimierung ist natürlich schon wichtig. Weil du willst natürlich immer so schnell wie möglich da hinkommen. Und du willst natürlich als Fahrstuhlbetreiber das auch alles so energieeffizient machen. Aber es ist im Prinzip genau derselbe Anspruch, den auch die Leute haben, nämlich möglichst zügig zum Ziel zu kommen. Und dann könnte ich mir halt vorstellen, und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass ich da jetzt raus bin aus dem Spiel, dass sie jetzt mittlerweile auch anfangen werden, einfach AI draufzuschmeißen. Also dass sie quasi einfach diese ganzen, wo stehen wie viele Leute und wo wollen die hin, Nummern in so einem Gebäude, einfach in die AI reinfüttern. Und damit sozusagen schon vorher wissen, wann wo Leute sind, die wohin wollen.
Mit Face Recognition gleich schon.
Dass die abends alle nach Hause kommen. Und deswegen müssen die Fahrsteller alle unten geparkt werden. Und morgens wollen die Leute alle nach unten. Und deswegen werden die schon mehr oben im Haus verpeilen.
Dass die überhaupt schon immer an der richtigen Stelle stehen, wenn die Leute irgendwie ankommen. Und dann so, ja, ich möchte den fünften Stock. Ja, ich weiß.
Was ist denn an diesem israelischen Sabbat-Fahrstuhl dran? Man hörte immer die Geschichte, da gäbe es halt Fahrstühle, die samstags in den Sabbat-Modus geschaltet würden. Weil orthodoxe Jugend keine Maschinen benutzen dürfen an einem Samstag. Und deswegen fahren die Fahrstühle halt einfach immer. Und wenn jemand drin ist, dann hält er an jedem Stockwerk an. Das heißt, du brauchst dich einfach reinstellen in den Fahrstuhl.
Aber sie haben die Maschine doch dann trotzdem benutzt. Nee, sie dürfen keine Maschinen bedienen.
Ah, bedienen, bedienen, das war's. Du, keine Ahnung. Also ich meine, bei uns hießen die Ravioli auch mal Herrgott's Bscheißle. Weil angeblich der Herrgott das nicht sieht, dass da Fleisch drin ist. Wenn da Teig außen rum ist.
Wikipedia weiß es. A Shabbat Elevator ist ein Elevator, der in einer speziellen Mode arbeitet. Er arbeitet automatisch, um die jüdischen Ziele zu verhindern, die Jüdinnen von den elektrischen Schlüsseln auf Shabbat abzulegen.
Und woher wussten die das vor ein paar tausend Jahren? Schon mit den elektrischen Schlüsseln?
Dennis musste da was erklären. Man nennt es Religion.
Und es hat mit Logik nichts zu tun.
Ach so, das ist das gleiche bei den anderen Versteher.
Es ist ein System, um Leute zu unsinnigen Handlungen anzuhalten. Man versucht ihnen einzureden, dass bestimmte Handlungen vorgenommen werden müssen, obwohl es dafür keine logische Erklärung gibt. Und der Grund, warum sie diese Handlung vornehmen sollen, ist, damit sie es tun. Damit sie lernen, unlogische Handlungen vorzunehmen, die den Willen einzelner entsprechen, damit sie nicht anfangen, etwas Sinnvolles zu tun. Und damit auch eine direkte Abhängigkeit desjenigen, der dieses Gesetz formuliert. Das ist eine ganz komische Sache. Man findet das an verschiedenen Orten. Wenn du jetzt mal im Netz eine Suche machst, gibt es schon eine ganze Menge Seiten zu. Das ist merkwürdig, aber mit Logik kann man da jetzt nicht ran. Was dürfen die denn alles da nicht machen?
Was mit Feuer war auch.
Da könnten sie doch mit der künstlichen Intelligenz wahrscheinlich irgendwie auch alle Probleme lösen. Also Samstag ist einfach KI-Tag.
Self-Driving Cars sind wahrscheinlich auch relativ groß dann, wenn sie mal da sind.
Könnte ja auch in Saudi-Arabien mal helfen, wenn die Frauen nicht fahren dürfen. Was ist denn mit selbst fahrenden Fahrzeugen? Da wären noch die ganzen indischen Gastarbeiter arbeitslos.
Ja, im Grund, die aus dem Land zu kegeln.
Wo du gerade AI im Fahrstuhl sagst, nächste Hitchhikers Guide to the Galaxy Reference. Der, wie heißt der, Depressive Elevator, den man erst überreden muss, oder Höhenangst hat er, oder was? Was war mit dem Fahrstuhl, den man erst überreden muss, dass er fährt?
Ja, der nervt halt rum.
Aber hat er Höhenangst oder war er depressive?
Der begrüßt immer die Leute und dann kommt er an und sagt hier, sag ich jetzt nichts, ach das sind die Türen.
Genau, es war mir eine Freude, mich für sie zu öffnen und wieder zu schließen und zu wissen, dass ich eine gute Arbeit getan habe.
Aber es war im zweiten Buch oder wo war denn das mit diesem Fahrstuhl? Es gab doch diesen Zelt oder...
Es gibt einen Fahrstuhl, oh man jetzt...
Also Marvin ist der Roboter, der depressiv ist.
Genau, ich glaube der Fahrstuhl, der Höhenangst hat. Also es war so mit AI und du musstest halt ihm gut zureden und dass das schon gut wird und jedes Mal so ein kleines Gespräch führen mit dem Fahrstuhl.
Moment, ich hab's gleich.
Ja, okay, jetzt in seiner... im Hitchhikers-Archiv wird geforscht. Bitte warten. Der gewünschte Podcast ist zurzeit leider nicht verfügbar. Ihr nächster Podcast-Gesprächspartner ist in zehn Minuten für Sie bereit.
Wieso erinnere ich mich denn jetzt gerade nicht an eine Elevator? Ist irgendwas warm mit Elevators?
Ja, Zephyrd ist da auch und Arthur, die haben da beide so ihre Geschichten mit.
Hier ist was mit einem entsprechenden Elevator. Das ist eigentlich das einzige E-Book, in das ich regelmäßig reinschaue. Da gibt es einfach immer so viel Schönes zu entdecken.
Where can I take you folks today?
said the elevator. Seems to be a popular floor today, said the elevator. Das war's aber auch schon hier in der Stelle.
Ja, wir suchen mal parallel noch. Irgendwie findet sich das bestimmt noch. Cybernetics Corporation.
Wir haben uns ganz schön an diesem Fahrstuhl-Thema festgebissen. So ist das. Das stimmt, aber irgendwie.
Ist ja sonst nichts los da draußen.
Hier gibt es noch einen Elevator, der spricht. Hallo, sagt der Elevator süßlich. Wenn du deinen Reise genießen möchtest, der wird schwifzend und platt, dann möchtest du dir die anderen Elevators aus den Offices der Galaktik, der Taxidegistrik, der Mobile Home Baby Foods und der Syrien State Mental Hospital, wo viele Exerius Cybernetics Corporation Exekutiven dich willkommen willkommen zu deinen Besuchern, Empathie und glückliche Geschichten der Außenseite. Ja, sagt Safad, steigend in die Stelle. Was sonst machst du, als auch zu reden? Gut, sagt Safad, das ist die Stelle. Oder runter, sagt der Elevator. Super. Ja, das ist super, das geht noch ein bisschen weiter, aber es ist sehr schön, ne? Auf Deutsch ist es auch sehr schön übersetzt. Wieso ist mir das nicht gleich eingefallen? Prostartige Szene.
Oh, hier guck mal, Tim liest die Bibel inklusive Kommentare. I would pay for that. Du hast ein neues Prasscast-Format.
Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass man Bibel nicht mit E schreibt.
Tatsächlich, also ich hab das früher tatsächlich gemacht.
Du hast ja auch deinem Discord die Bibel vorgelesen.
Nein, nein, den Anhalter. Also ich hab mehreren Leuten den Anhalter vorgelesen. Auf Deutsch allerdings. Also ich war halt so ein, ich war so drin, also ich war so ein Anhaltern-Nerd, dass ich einfach größte Freude dabei verspürt habe, die ganze Zeit das Buch zu lesen und konnte mir auch nichts Schöneres vorstellen als anderen Leuten daraus vorzulesen.
Aber nur aus dem ersten oder aus?
Aus was auch immer, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube damals hatte ich sogar auf meinen Reisen immer alle Bücher dabei und hab dann in irgendwelchen Hostels oder so, wo ich halt auf Leute gestoßen bin, die ich dann halt irgendwie schnell in diesen was du kennst, dieses Buch nicht, ich muss ja daraus vorlesen, Modus und so, ne? Also man muss ja dann sozusagen, als guter Diener.
Wie wild treuer Christ.
Ja, ich weiß schon, wie man den Sermon an den Mann bringt. Ja, dann hab ich mich hängen, was auch zur Folge hatte, dass ich bestimmte Szenen halt auch wirklich, also es gibt ja einfach Szenen in diesem Buch, die sind so episch, die kann man einfach gar nicht oft genug vorlesen. Deswegen, weil ich jetzt auch gerade, ehrlich gesagt, etwas überrascht, dass mir das jetzt nicht unmittelbar einfiel.
Das ist eine ganz tolle Stelle. Ich hab das zu der Zeit gelesen, als ich dieses Projekt auch an der UDK, also es war so, ob das eine mit dem anderen, also in welcher Reihenfolge das passiert ist, aber es war so unmittelbar zusammen, deswegen fand ich die Stelle auch immer so besonders interessant. Und ich mein, jetzt, wenn das wird ja auch kommen, dass die dann irgendwann mit dir quatschen oder so weiter.
Marvin und die Kampfmaschine ist auch so eine großartige Szene, wo irgendwie die große, gewaltige Kampfmaschine irgendwie hinter Arthur und den anderen hinterher ist. Und sie lassen dann Marvin zurück, um sich dieses Problems anzunehmen. Und Marvin stellt sich halt einfach vor, diese Kampfmaschine und fängt halt an mit ihr zu quatschen. Was ja an mehreren Stellen im Anhalter auch interessante Folgen hat. Also unter anderem gab es ja dieses Raumschiff, mit dem sich Marvin... Ah ja, genau, das war das. Da waren sie nämlich auch unter Attacke. Und auf einmal sind alle Leute, die hinter ihnen her waren, waren auf einmal alle tot. Oder auf einmal, weil diese ganze Angriffssituation war weg und sie wussten nicht warum. Und dann sind sie halt zurück und haben dann Marvin angetroffen, der ihnen erzählt hat, dass er sich mit diesem gegnerischen Kampfraumschiff unterhalten hat. Und in seinen ganzen existenzialistischen Ansichten über das Universum und die Sinnlosigkeit des Lebens dargelegt hat, woraufhin dieses Raumschiff Selbstmord begangen hat. Was dann diese ganze Kampfhandlung dann eingestellt hat. Und als er dann dieser großen Kampfmaschine gegenüber steht, ist seine Argumentation so, so. Da steht dann halt einfach so diesen Weg und dann so die große Kampfmaschine mit seinen ganzen Waffenarsenalen vollkommen überdimensioniert, vollkommen aufgeregt. Was ist denn mit dir? Warum stehst du denn hier und so? Ja, ich wurde von Menschen hier hingestellt, um dich aufzuhalten. Und was denkst du, womit haben sie mich ausgestattet, um dich, riesige Kampfmaschine, unbesiegbares Maschinen zu stoppen? Was verdammt irre Tolles, würde ich denken. Rat doch mal! Und dann, na ja, kommt dann auf jeden Fall ein paar erfundene Waffensysteme, die ihm gerade einfallen und so. Dann machen wir noch so, nein, das auch nicht, nein, das auch nicht und so weiter. Ja, dann komm ich nicht drauf. Womit haben sie mich zurückgelassen? Mit nichts! Was mit nichts? Um sich mir entgegenzustellen. Das ist aber wirklich wie, ja ist das nicht wirklich? Das macht die Maschine dann so wütend, dass sie sich irgendwie in diesem ganzen Klimbin glaube ich selber zerstört. Also es ist einfach immer wieder unfassbar, was so dieses Buch an die Tausend irgendwie rauskommt.
Ich merke gerade, ich habe wahrscheinlich auch schon wieder einige Zwischengeschichten vergessen und könnte den wahrscheinlich jetzt mal wieder lesen bei Gelegenheit.
Ja, vorlesen und öffentlich vorlesen ist natürlich wieder so ein Copyright-Problem, ne?
Ja, ja, leider, leider, wann läuft das denn aus für den Hitchhiker's Guide?
Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Gut, von Fahrstühlen zum Anhalter.
Per Anhalter durch den Fahrstuhlschacht.
Wir haben wohl auch ein paar Fahrstuhl-Nerds in unserem Hörerkreis, wie wir das richtig gesehen haben, so schnell wieder die Lösungen kamen. Wollen wir nochmal über coole Sachen reden?
Soll ich mal erzählen, wie geil mein Urlaub war? Der war so geil und so entspannt, dass ich wiedergekommen bin und mein Passwort vergessen habe. Welches?
Hast du entspannungssteigende Stoffe genommen?
Das Passwort, was alle anderen Passwörter aufschließt.
Das Passwort, mit dem ich meinen Online-Backup verschlüssel, das Passwort, was meine Keychain lockt, das Passwort, was meine Full-Disk-Encryption lockt.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Also ich hab's nicht vergessen, weil das Problem ist, eigentlich, ich hatte dieses Passwort, ich hab das seit schon ein paar Jahren, eigentlich schon zu lange, eigentlich hab ich früher öfters meine Passwörter gewechselt und bin jetzt so in diesen Bequemlichkeitsmodus gekommen und hab dieses Passwort behalten. Und ich weiß nicht mehr, wie dieses Passwort konkret aussieht, weil es so in den Muscle-Memory übergegangen ist, dass ich nicht mehr, also ich denk nicht drüber nach, ich setz mich halt an den Rechner und ich tipp das Passwort 20-mal am Tag. Brit, passt schon, ne? Und ich kam nach dem Urlaub wieder und am ersten Tag kein Problem. Am zweiten Tag, es strahlte scheinbar noch nach, die Entspannung, hab ich so ein Paket abgeholt so und dann setz ich mich so wieder ran und tipp so, Passwort falsch. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr so längere Passwörter habt oder irgendwie kryptische Komplexe, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht habt ihr ja mal diesen Moment, dass irgendwie, hä? Okay, noch mal, hä? Geht nicht. Und dann beim dritten Mal klappt's halt, ne? Kennt ihr das? Ja, alles schon mal gehabt. Hatte ich auch schon mal so einen Aussetzer und dann irgendwie fängt sich das. Aber weil ich gerade was auch für den Kollegen raussuchen musste, also ich war so ein bisschen in so einer kleinen Drucksituation, ja? Jetzt an meinen Rechner zu kommen, kommen zu müssen. Und mit jedem Fehlversuch stieg so ein bisschen das Stresslevel quasi in mir, sodass ich gar nicht diesen kleinen Ruhemoment hatte, um nochmal, okay jetzt nochmal ganz langsam, ne? Und das war dann so krass, dass ich dachte, okay ich geh jetzt mal Mittag essen und komm wieder. Und das Problem war, ich war mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich 90% von dem Passwort richtig eintipp, einfach nur vom Flow, vom Sound, vom Gefühl in den Fingern, Muscle Memory und so weiter. Ich war mir sicher, ich bin nah dran, aber offensichtlich war ein Zeichen, Schiff, irgendwas. Und da ich nicht mehr weiß, wie es aussieht oder was es konkret ist, ich hab's den ganzen Tag nicht geschafft, dieses Passwort richtig einzunehmen. Und das hat natürlich mein Stresslevel nicht verringert, weil sie wissen schon, was ich gerade meinte. Das ist halt das Passwort.
Du hast dieses Passwort nicht irgendwo nochmal?
Ich hatte das ganz früher, als ich mir das neu überlegt hatte, hatte ich das auf dem Zettel und hatte das erst in der Brieftasche dabei, falls ich es vergesse. Sozusagen noch in der Lernphase. Und irgendwo in meiner Wohnung ist dieser Zettel bestimmt noch, aber ich weiß nicht wo. Lessons learned. Ich sagte ja, ganz viele aus diesem Erlebnis. So, und dann saß ich halt da. Und auch an Tag zwei wach ich so auf, ich dachte mir, okay, Nacht drüber schlafen. Und das Problem war, in dem Moment, wo ich diesen Lock-In-Prompt gesehen hab, war das Stresslevel schon wieder da. Weil ich wusste, okay, ich muss das jetzt richtig eintippen, sonst wird es langsam ein bisschen unangenehm halt. Das heißt, ich war schon in diesem Modus, dass ich gar nicht hier ganz entspannt, nicht drüber nachdenken, einfach drauf los tippen. Und dann, je öfter ich das versucht hab, habe ich ja sozusagen mehr oder weniger das falsche Passwort gelernt. Und am zweiten Tag dachte ich dann, alles klar, ich fange jetzt so richtig an, möglichst strukturiert das zu rekonstruieren. Ich hab ja da auch einen Blogpost, das war ja dieser Blogpost, den ich dazu auch geschrieben hab, um jetzt mal Leuten, die ein ähnliches Problem haben, so eine kleine Hilfestellung zu geben. Ich hab erstmal 20x, 30x, 40x mein Passwort so in Textdokument getippt, um zu gucken, was ist der Teil, der immer gleich ist, um sozusagen festzustellen, welcher Teil ist am wahrscheinlichsten richtig, weil er einfach immer gleich kommt. Und wo sind die Sachen, die manchmal so und manchmal so vielleicht sein könnten. Ich hab aufgeschrieben, welche Zeichen ich üblicherweise in Passwörtern verwende. Das ist nicht der komplette Satz. Ich hab verschiedene Längen eingegrenzt. Ich wusste mindestens 18, könnte bis zu 21 sein, wenn ich jetzt wirklich total daneben liege mit es fehlt nur ein Zeichen oder ein Zeichen ist falsch. Und dann hab ich angefangen, weil manuelle Variationen nicht funktioniert haben. Ich hab mir jede Variante auch aufgeschrieben, damit ich die nicht immer wieder falsch probiere oder so. Aber ich bin nicht drauf gekommen. Und dann war das einzige, erstens neue SSD kaufen, Clean Install und die andere Krypto-Platte erstmal noch aufheben, falls es mir wieder einfällt. Aber ich musste halt wieder arbeiten können. Und das war der cleanste Clean Install meines bisherigen Lebens. Ich hatte glücklicherweise noch ein unencrypted Time Machine Backup, was ein paar Monate alt war. Aber die Keychain war ja trotzdem damit verschlüsselt. Das heißt, an die ganzen Passwörter. Und für die ganzen SSH-Keys, und ich hab eine Known-Host-List von 500 Zeilen. Und meine Passphrase für den Key, die ist halt lang und mächtig und in der Keychain gespeichert. Das heißt, diese ganzen Hosts unerreichbar. Online-Banking, PayPal, Seriennummern, alles, alles, alles. Na ja, also Clean-Install angefangen. Und dann auf einer anderen Kiste parallel angefangen, mein Passwort zu bruteforcen.
Ernsthaft?
Weil es dir einfach nicht mehr gekommen ist? Bis heute nicht?
Na ja, ich hab's ja erfolgreich gebruteforced.
Du hast dein Passwort erfolgreich gebruteforced?
Na ja, wenn du jetzt gerade zugehört hättest, richtig. Ich wusste ja, dass 90% vom Passwort richtig sind. Und ich konnte den Zeichensatz eingrenzen und ich konnte die Längenvariable eingrenzen. Also es war maximal drei Zeichen zu kurz, sag ich mal. Also es war so ein Unterschied, so ein Spielraum.
Und auch an welcher Stelle natürlich?
Genau, ich hab auch noch, also durch diese 40-mal-Passwort-Eintippe über ein paar Tage halt, habe ich gesehen, ok, der erste Teil ist immer gleich, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass der richtig ist. Und der hintere Teil, da ist manchmal irgendwie ein Wackler drin und so eine Unsicherheit auch beim Tippen, da ist wahrscheinlich, wo ich mich verhasple. Das heißt, ich konnte auch die Stelle eingrenzen. Ich musste jetzt nicht 18 oder 21 Zeichen Passwörter bootfassen, das kannst du dann komplett knicken. Aber bei mir war es im Prinzip 6 Stellen, wo ich nicht wusste genau, wie ist die Reihenfolge oder Groß-Kleinschreibung oder, ne? Und für die 6 Stellen wusste ich aber, jetzt konnte ich zumindest die Zeichen eingrenzen. Ich wusste in etwa, was für Buchstaben oder Zeichen da vorkommen. Und dann googelt, ok, Passwortcracker, oder Bootforcer, was macht man da? Der Klassiker John the Ripper war natürlich gleich ganz vorne mit dabei. Das ist halt so ein Toolkit, was halt alle möglichen Hashes sozusagen Bootforcen kann, möglichst effektiv. Und das Schöne ist, es kommt mit einem Converter zum Beispiel um die OSX-Keychain, den Hasch zu extrahieren, den Crypto-Hash, um dann dagegen zu Bootforcen. Und davor habe ich aber noch ein anderes Tool benutzt, um die Permutation zu erzeugen. Weil ich ja wusste, sechs Stellen, der Teil ist sicher, mit dem Character-Set für die sechs Stellen. Und du kannst auch noch sagen, an der Stelle kommt ein Sonderzeichen, an der Stelle kommt ein Buchstabe aus diesem Character-Set. Also man sollte in der Lage sein, das so weit wie möglich einzugrenzen, um Erfolgschancen zu haben. Und dann habe ich mir eine 4 oder 8 GB Wordlist erstellt. Und ich für alle, die jetzt sagen, ja fang doch erstmal kleine an. Ich habe kleine angefangen, ja. Ich habe mit ganz wenig variabel, also nur eine Stelle durchprobiert. Und dann irgendwann dachte ich, fuck it, ich komm nicht drauf, okay, bruteforcen, jetzt 6 Stellen, das File ist 8 GB groß, das dauert bis 22 Uhr, ich habe am Morgen angefangen. Fuck it, let's do it, ja, auf dem Quadcoaxion. Und wäre das nicht gegangen, hätte ich mir eine Kiste mit einer fetten Grafikkarte geholt und hätte das auf der Grafikkarte gebruteforced. Dafür heißt das Tool übrigens Hashcat. Na ja, das Ding ist, ich hab das auf dem Server gestartet, auf dem Xeon und in einem T-Max und du siehst halt die ganzen Versuche, die so durchscrollen.
Ja, das ist ja das, was es richtig langsam macht, oder? Das Scrollen.
Keine Ahnung, war schnell genug auf jeden Fall für diese 8 GB bis zum Abend und ich hab halt immer mal wieder über den Tag reingeguckt und sehe so die Permutation und dachte mir, ja das könnte es gewesen sein, aber es rollt dran vorbei und ich hatte ja vorher schon gebroodforced und ich viel probiert und dachte, das kann noch nicht sein. Ist jetzt auf der SSD oder so das Bit geflippt, was irgendwie die Krypto irgendwie zerdorkt hat oder keine Ahnung, ne? Aber irgendwann um 14 Uhr, sonst was, gucke ich ins T-Max rein und... Katsching, da war das Passwort und ich hab's gesehen und dachte mir...
Stimmt, hättest du auch gleich drauf kommen können.
Hätte ich auch gleich drauf kommen können, aber es haben tatsächlich zwei Zeichen gefehlt. Also die sind mir irgendwie aus dem Muscle Memory rausge...
Am Ende...
Ne, mittendrin.
Also zwei waren falsch.
Ja, haben gefehlt.
Ach...
Ich hab die...
Nicht lang genug.
Die waren im Flow irgendwie plötzlich raus.
Vielleicht hast du dir irgendwann mal zusätzlich reingemacht. Lass mich raten, war es 23? Keine Antwort, habt ihr gemerkt?
Also, wenn ihr ein ähnliches Problem habt und ihr wisst sozusagen noch weite Teile des Passworts, dann habt ihr durchaus eine Chance, wenn es, sagen wir mal, ich würde sagen maximal acht Stellen, habt ihr eine realistische Chance, das bei Zeiten noch wieder zu finden, vielleicht sogar zehn heutzutage, wenn es nicht ein mega riesen Zeichensatz ist, den ihr verwendet. Aber, ja... Ich pack jetzt den Link zu dem Blogpost mal in die Show Notes für alle die, vielleicht mal ein ähnliches Problem haben. Achso, es ist sogar schon da drin, genau. Ja, war auf jeden Fall eine krasse Erfahrung und ich habe so einige Lektionen daraus gelernt. Erstens gibt es ja dieses berühmte XKCD-Comic zum Thema Password Security. Das kam aber sehr viel später, also da hatte ich das Passwort schon längst gehabt und das war ein kryptisches. Mein neues Passwort ist deutlich weniger kryptisch, aber länger. Also so wie es auch in diesem berühmten XKCD vorgeschlagen wurde. Ich habe mir dieses Mal tatsächlich die Recovery Keys für meine Full-Disk-Encryption als auch mein Masterpasswort ausgedruckt und an einen für mich jederzeit wieder aufrufbaren Ort zu Hause deponiert. Ich habe schon darüber gedacht, ob ich so einen Umschlag auch mache und das wie so ein Haustürschlüssel auch bei einem Freund oder einer Freundin noch deponiere. Weil an der Stelle habe ich echt gemerkt, in dieser Key-Channel, in meinem Masterpasswort, dingsbombs, da ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr sehr viel wichtige Information drin und schon allein dieser Server-Access, dieses Thema, das war eigentlich das Nervigste, weil PayPal, Online-Banking, das zu resetten, ging relativ schnell und problemfrei. Aber Server-Keys tauschen von 500 Hosts, die mir nicht alle gehören oder wo ich nicht den Service-Support anrufen kann oder auch nicht will. Das wäre richtig scheiße gewesen.
Also, Rote Keule, nicht? Bin ich der hier so Vader?
Ich wollte nicht deinen Job wegnehmen.
Also, ja, Lektion Nummer eins. Unencrypted Backups können schon auch nützlich sein, um an die Daten dann nochmal ranzukommen, aber dann halt lokal irgendwo zu Hause. Also, ich hab jetzt nicht so ein Bedrohungsszenario, dass ich denke, die CIA kommt in den Moment und findet dann auf meiner Backup-Platte irgendwie...
Ja, wenn die beiden brechen und dein Zeug mitnehmen.
Ja.
Safe ist auf jeden Fall nochmal eine interessante Option.
Aber, wie gesagt, das Ding ist halt, die wirklich kritische Information ist in meiner Keychain drin. Und die ist so oder so verschlüsselt. Und dafür hab ich mir jetzt einfach, ich hab's mir ausgedruckt und an eine Stelle gepackt, die jetzt nicht so offensichtlich auffindbar ist und auch nicht weiter beschriftet ist. Aber ich weiß ganz genau, wo es ist. Und ich finde, ist da wieder. Das soll mir nicht nochmal passieren. Ja, du kannst ja auch den Schlüssel verteilen. Also, du kannst ja sozusagen einen Teil dem einen freuen.
Nee, einfach acht Stellen weglassen. Wenn man's vergisst, dann muss man halt eben nochmal die zehn Stunden investieren.
Das ist doch okay.
Ich hätte es gerne eigentlich auch mit diesem Hashcat mal ausprobiert, weil das ist schon so die moderne Variante von diesem John-River.
Du hast doch ein Auto, oder? Ja, dann habe ich da so ein Projekt für dich.
Wir sprechen off the air darüber, nehme ich an.
Nee, eigentlich wollen wir im Club einen Rechner basteln, wo halt mehrere Grafikkarten reinkommen, damit wir genau dieses Hashcat benutzen können. Und wir müssen den Rechner nur von mir zu Hause im Club kriegen.
Und dazu brauchst du ein Auto?
Das ist ein Gaming-Rechner, so ein großer. Da passen drei Grafikkarten rein und da ist noch Luft genug dazwischen, dass die halt lüften können. Also das ist wirklich so ein Board, wo ziemlich viel PCI-Slot Platz ist.
Also dieses XKCD zum Thema Password Strengths 936, das kann man echt nicht oft genug wiederholen. Nicht oft genug darauf hinweisen. Weil ich muss auch sagen, dieses ganze... Troubadour mit Nullen und Groß- und Kleinbuchstaben. Und es ist ja auch so mittlerweile bei den Nerds eingesickert, dass das irgendwie jetzt der angemessene Weg wäre, dass so ein cooles Passwort, so ein gutes Passwort aussieht, dass es ja teilweise auch schon enforced wird. Man merkt das jetzt immer, wenn man so so eine Webseite will, dass du einen Account hast. Ja, okay, gib dir mal ein Passwort. Und wenn sie zumindest HTML halbwegs auf die Backe bekommen haben, dann kann ja Safari irgendwie gleich eins vorschlagen. Und das nehme ich auch in der Regel, weil die sind irgendwie so halbwegs sane. Safari hat ja immer so wesentlich so Buchstaben, paar Zahlen, vier Teile mit Bindestrichen getrennt. Und dann kommt da irgendwie so 16 Zeichen mit irgendwie halbwegs brauchbar Entropiebe raus. Und dann kommen ja so diese Schlaumeier-Webseiten mit so Ja, da ist aber jetzt kein Sonderzeichen drin. Oder kein Großbuchstabe. Oder nicht gemischt. Oder es müssen so und so viele Zahlen und so und so viele Sonderzeichen drin sein. Also so völlig zugekniffener Arsch.
Aber dann nur maximal 16 Zeichen.
Oder dein Passwort ist zu lang. Da hab ich ja schon wirklich den Baseball-Schläger. Also was reitet diese Leute? Heute hatte ich das hier. Was war das? Da war es nicht zu lang, aber da wollte er auch irgendwie mein Passwort nicht haben.
Einmal hatte ich was, das war richtig scheiße.
Dominos, genau, dieses blöde Pizza-Bude. Wir bestellten bisher immer bei Joys jetzt irgendwie bei Dominos. Und er wollte dann auch irgendwie das von Safari angebotene Ding nicht. Weil, und das war halt locker mal 12 oder 14 Zeichen lang, was mir Safari da angeboten hat. Und die Webseite monierte halt, dass das Passwort halt 8 Zeichen mindestens haben muss. Kannst du nicht zählen oder was? Also, wenn schon Computer auf einmal nicht mehr zählen können.
Wir hatten einen lustigen Bug und zwar... Schlimm, ey. Die Webseite und die Clients hatten eine unterschiedliche Meinung davon, wie das Passwort auszusehen hat. Und zwar, die Webseite hat keine Längenbeschränkung entforst. Aber ich glaube, es war der Android Client, der wollte maximal 30 Zeichen akzeptieren. Das ist auch geil. Und es dauert natürlich eine Weile, bis du irgendjemanden findest, der tatsächlich ein 31 Zeichen langes Passwort macht, dieses Passwort auf der Webseite erzeugt und dann versucht, sich mit einer Android-App einzuloggen. Und das dann geht's nicht. War natürlich so ein bisschen so blöd gelaufen.
Ich hatte mal irgendeine El Chippo-Webseite, die meinte, ich darf im Passwort nicht zweimal den gleichen Buchstaben haben. Oder zweimal den gleichen hintereinander.
Geht mal.
Und vor allem sind das alles so Maßnahmen, die die Entropie eigentlich auch senken.
Auf jeden Fall, weil es gab ja auch vor John the Ripper und was weiß ich, das Hashcat. Früher gab es so das Tool, das hieß einfach nur Crack. Und da war auch so ein Pearl-Tool dabei. Damit konnte man sich auch diese Dictionaries, also diese Worte, die Permutation, einmal erstellen lassen. Und da konntest du natürlich auch genau sagen, wie das auszusehen hat. Und wenn du wusstest, dass irgendein nur klein oder nur groß oder zumindest ein Groß ist, dann hat er das auch genau so gemacht. Und dann hatst du das alles. Das heißt, jede Vorgabe für ein Passwort erarbeitet beim Brute Force eigentlich ein bisschen Arbeit.
Na, für vor allen Dingen diese kurzen Passwörter, also bis zu zehn Zeichen. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn das Character-Set nur alphanumerisch ist, gibt es ja Rainbow Tables sowieso schon. Da ist euer Passwort im Zweifel dann schon drin.
Ja, nee, weil heute da gibt es ja einen Salt.
Also hört auf XKCD und euer Passwort sollte lauten Correct Horse Battery Stap.
Ja, wie war das? Das war doch auch so eine, war das nicht so hier vom Poste, ja, wir haben ja schon mal über Passwörter gesprochen, aber der hatte doch auch diesen Post. Der CCC kührt das sicherste Passwort 2015 und das Passwort, das sicherste Passwort 2015 ist so und so. Das war auch richtig gut.
Genau, das sicherste Passwort ist MB2R5OHF-0T.
Ja, das war echt eine Knallerbildung.
Genau, und dann gibt es noch die Sparkasse mit 5 Zeichen. Sie nennen es dann PIN.
Die Zeichenfolge MB2R5OHF-0T ist einfach makellos. Sie beinhaltet Großbuchstaben, Kleinbuchstaben, Satzzeichen und Ziffern. Ohne dass an irgendeiner Stelle zwei Zeichen der gleichen Kategorie aufeinander folgen würden, schwärmt Malte Winkler vom CCC.
Deshalb kann man mit Fug und Recht sagen, dass ich mit dem B2R5OHF-0T schütze. Der ist sicher, garantiert.
Gab es da noch nicht so eine Extension, dass irgendwie, wer meint, das würde gar nicht stimmen, und hat dann aber noch ein Zeichen hinten dran gegangen oder irgendein Scheid?
Auch mit gängigen Mess-Tools zur Passwort-Sicherheit. Und dann verlinken sie auch so großartig, wie sicher ist mein password.de hier das Passwort zum Testen eingeben. Oh Mann, sicherlich. Das Passwort wird nicht gespeichert.
Das hier eingegebene Passwort bleibt auf deinem Rechner.
Getunnelt durch HTML.
Großartig.
Genau, das Ganze natürlich auch mit HTTP und so.
Wir können alles außer sicher. Apropos sicher, Tim.
Warte mal, meinen die das ernst?
Es gibt Webseiten, wo du deine Bitcoin-Adresse erstellen kannst.
Das ist ja nicht zu glauben, die meinen das ernst.
Die Welt ist schlecht, wirklich.
Wie ist denn dein Passwort?
Na Passwort 1, 2, 3.
Da ist auch so ein Typ, der heißt einer von diesen Late Night Show Leuten Jimmy Fallon, glaube ich. Vielleicht verwechsel ich ihn jetzt gerade auch mit einem anderen, aber ich glaube, er war es. Der ist dann tatsächlich irgendwie durch die Straßen von New York gelatscht und hat die Leute nach ihrem Passwort gefragt. Und die sagen es dann auch. In die Fernsehkamera.
Viel schöner war eine Szene, die ich letztens an der Tram hatte, als ich irgendwie zur Arbeit gefahren bin. So die Konstellation Eltern, Tochter. Es ging um irgendwas wegen E-Mail einloggen und Router Passwort, wo sie schon den Unterschied nicht verstanden haben. Und dann kam so die Tochter mit, ja, also in eurem grünen Buch, da stehen noch eure Passwörter drin und das müsst ihr dann da eingeben. Das fand ich auch sehr schön.
In ihrem grünen Buch.
Im grünen Buch, genau. Auf dem Nachttisch.
Aber die Frage ist doch, wie kann man denn eigentlich jetzt die Passwort-Technologie überwinden? Es gibt ja auch schon so erste, weil ich meine, was klar ist, irgendwie Passwörter funktionieren nicht large scale. Also die Menschen...
Also die Menschen sind das Problem.
Ja, sie können sich... und ich kann das auch verstehen. Also ich meine, das ist irgendwie auch komplex. Und umso älter du wirst, ich meine, Hucke entfällt jetzt schon sein Passwort. Er hat es natürlich sozusagen, hat sein XKCD nicht gelesen und jetzt weiß er es besser. Aber die Leute kriegen ja auch Scheiße erzählt mit den ganzen Webseiten, die einem dann irgendwie zu irgendwas zwingen. Das finde ich überhaupt am schlimmsten. Dass sie so nerdig sind. Gut, meinetwegen, dann überprüft ihr halt irgendwelche Sachen. Ja, könnt ihr machen. Aber haltet mich doch bitte nicht davon ab, mir etwas zu wählen, was an sich sicher ist, aber was mit meinem Hirn auch funktioniert und nicht nur mit eurem Hirn. Aber seht ihr denn etwas, wie man auf Passwörter verzichten kann? Also es gibt ja jetzt schon einige Webseiten, die nur noch anmelden per Link. Also gehst du auf die Webseite und dann kriegst du halt einen Link per E-Mail. Im Prinzip genauso, wie du Password Recovery machst, jedes Mal zum einen. Also Slack hat so eine Funktion. Slack kannst du dich anmelden ohne Passwort. Indem du halt immer diesen Backchannel-E-Mail benutzt. Ich meine, wenn das endemisch wird mit der Sicherheit, die wir im E-Mail haben.
Für den genannten Hörer um Sicherheit waren Airquotes.
Also ich meine, eine Sache in Norwegen, die man auf jeden Fall auch beobachten kann, da ist die gemeine Sicherheitslage auch eine ganz andere. Da werden auch so Haustüren und so, die werden ja nicht abgeschlossen. Also da ist einfach alles offen, weil überhaupt da gar nicht davon ausgegangen wird, dass überhaupt jemand... Da ist halt auch keiner. Also vielleicht ist eine Lösung, ich gehst nach Norwegen und...
Das machen die aber auch mit den Haustüren. Und lassen die Schlüssel dranstecken.
Bei meinen 80ern war das auch noch so. Da stand plötzlich der Nachbar beim Mittagessen am Tisch und der kommt über den Seiteneingang rein, das ist einfach so.
Ja, aber im Internet ist halt auch in Norwegen die Bronke.
Aber keine Ahnung, ich bin mit allen Alternativen auch nicht zufrieden. Also Biometrie will ich nicht. Diese Two-Factor-Authentication wird einem ja immer mehr gezwungen, über so sichere Kanäle wie SMS abzuwickeln, statt so eine App laufen zu lassen, wo man sich wieder die Recovery-Keys merken müsste, weil wenn das Telefon stirbt oder crasht und dieser Authenticator nicht mehr geht, dann ist man halt auch wieder...
Oder noch viel schlimmer, du hast halt so ein Hardware-Token. Ja, und dann läuft das irgendwann ab und irgendwie kriegt es die Firma nicht auf die Reihe neue Hardware-Tokens zu liefern und dann kannst du dich nicht anmelden, weil das Hardware-Token ist halt expired.
Das ging ja mit diesen Two-Factor-Authentication los, wo ich das zumindest kennenlernte, bei World of Warcraft, aber da wurden ja so viele Accounts geklaut und dann konntest du für relativ wenig Euro... Ja, drei, Joans, glaube ich. So ein kleines Gerät holen, so eine Art Schlüsselanhänger mit so einem kleinen Display und... Da hast du auch WV gespielt. Ich hab das Ding nie gehabt. Ich hab immer diese App benutzt, wo das das Gleiche geht und dann konnte man da sein Account sichern. Ich fand das eigentlich ganz cool, nervt aber auch, weil man muss dann immer sein Telefon irgendwie dann klicken und so und das eintippen.
Oh, du hast ein richtiges RSA-Token.
Ich hab ein richtiges RSA-Token. Ja, ein Kollege von mir, dem ist heute sein RSA-Token abgelaufen. Er hat das irgendwie vor 2,5 Wochen ein neues sich geklickt, aber irgendwie ging der Request nicht durch. Jetzt steht er ohne Token da, was ein bisschen doof ist, weil er von Dubai aus arbeitet.
Da gibt es bestimmt Import-Export-Restriktionen für.
Was ich noch gemacht hab, ist, ich hatte auch irgendwie meine Bitcoins bei Mt.
Gox, kurz bevor es schief ging.
Dann dachte ich auch, naja, es ist ja eigentlich besser, wenn man seinen Account unterstützt und hat mir diese Kreditkarte, wo so ein Display mit drin ist, schicken lassen von denen, was dann auch mit meinem Account verbunden ist, wo dann auch immer irgendwie da so eine Zahl kommt, die man da online eingeben muss. Die hab ich auch immer noch, aber die ist natürlich für einen Arsch jetzt. Schickes Andenken, aber ansonsten, weißt du, cool, ist wirklich so dünn wie eine Kreditkarte und trotzdem Display drin. So ein LCD-Dings. Und 10er-Pad auch noch, genau.
Apropos sichere Kanäle beim Fliegen entdeckt, fand ich ja sehr spannend, mit was die Bundesdruckerreise wirbt. Mit sicheren, mit sicheren E-Mail-Kommunikationen. Das dauert ein bisschen mit dem Upload. Ich war irgendwie schockiert für diese Werbung. Dein Internet ist schnell.
Nee, das kann ja auch der Slack-Server sein. Und die Cloud nicht skaliert.
Hätten sie mal da was geklickt. Abzera...
Ab geht er.
Ja, wir müssen nochmal kurz Sendepause. Bitte warten Sie, please hold the line. Der nächste Podcaster ist sofort für Sie verfügbar. Ja, aber Tim ist schon wieder völlig raus aus der Passwortfrage, denn er hat den Post von vor einer Stunde entdeckt, den jemand in den Chat gepostet hat, über neue iPhones.
Ja, ich habe es selber rausgesucht.
Ihre Kunden erwarten Sicherheit. Bei jeder E-Mail, das würde ich sogar noch unterstreichen, aber was hat die Bundesdrücklerei mit Sicherheit zu tun?
Aber was ist denn jetzt eurer Meinung nach der Weg, der sozusagen Passwörter in Zukunft ablöst?
Es gibt keinen ordentlichen Weg.
Denke ich auch.
Ich bin nicht visionär genug in der Hinsicht. Ich sehe da auch keine Alternative, die alle Probleme von allen anderen Verfahren löst. Also ich bin ja sowieso der Meinung, Convenience und Sicherheit gibt es nicht. Gleich zur gleichen Zeit.
Naja, aber dieses Two-Factor ist ja schon gar nicht schlecht. Also eine Sache, die ich cool finde, ist...
Ja, aber Two-Factor ist ja nur ein zweiter Faktor.
Der erste ist Passwörter.
Naja, löst nicht das Passwort ab, sondern ergänzt nur das Passwort um etwas anderes. Um die Unzulänglichkeiten von Passwörtern in irgendeiner Form in den Griff zu bekommen.
Vielleicht ist das halt der Weg, weil Passwörter willst dein Leben lang immer längere Passwörter eingeben. Wenn die Brute Forcer irgendwann mal 20 Zeichen so nebenbei hacken, wie viel willst du denn merken in deinem Kopf?
Nee, aber...
Irgendwann skaliert das halt nicht mehr mit dem Merken.
Na gut, wenn ich mir jetzt mal anschaue, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt hat. Mittlerweile hatten wir wieder bei Dropbox gerade die Meldungen. Was weiß ich, 28 Millionen, keine Ahnung. 60 Millionen? 60 Millionen Passwörter geklaut.
Aber irgendwie 2012 schon. Und jetzt ist ihnen aufgefallen.
Na ja, jetzt haben sie halt eine Kopie gefunden bekommen, gesehen, in die Hände bekommen, was weiß ich.
Gefunden bekommen, sehr schön.
Na ja, also was weiß ich. Ich hab das so gesehen und war dann erstmal entspannt, weil ich hatte, ich hab ne Mail von denen bekommen. Offenbar hatte ich mein Passwort auch seit 2012 nicht geändert.
Genau, weil nur die haben so ne Mail nämlich bekommen.
Schaute mir das Passwort kurz an, stellte fest, dass das ein Passwort ist, was halt auch generiert war. Also es war nicht so aus meinen alten Zeiten, wo ich mir wirklich noch Passwortreviews gemacht hab oder mir sehr einfache Passwörter oder sowas gewählt hab oder zumindest mehr als einem Ort verwendet habe. Das war also ohnehin schonmal unik, nur für Dropbox. Und ich hab auch seit es das gibt Two-Factor Authentication bei Dropbox an.
Also doch Two-Factor.
Ja klar, um halt gerade solche Leaks zu verhindern. Also an der Stelle, sie meinen ja, sie hätten nichts gemerkt. Wie missbraucht worden wäre. Kann ja durchaus sein, dass es jemand in die Hände bekommen hat. Und dann keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber Two-Factor ist ja dann auch nicht unbedingt ein sicheres Ding. Weil wenn die...
Ja, aber wenn du jetzt mal ein Passwort gehabt hättest.
Moment, wenn jemand die Passwörter klaut, dann klaut er doch die Two-Factor Secrets gleich mit.
Nee, nee, warte, er hat ja nicht die Passwörter geklaut, er hat nur die Hashes geklaut. Die konnten damit ja nichts anfangen. Sonst wäre das ja schon früher aufgeflogen. Die konnten nur auch da durchtesten oder so, aber...
Es gab ja noch gar keine Two-Factor-Assignations.
Also sie hätten es halt auch gegen Rainbow Tables oder so halten können.
Nee, es ist auch gesaltet.
Die haben da diesen Becrypt benutzt, teilweise. Nicht immer, manche waren nicht so gut, weil die haben verschiedene, aber es war schon nicht so jetzt, dass da alles weit offen steht, sondern da musste man schon auch irgendwie pro User...
Na ja, gut, auf jeden Fall, mittlerweile ist es so, dass ich eigentlich auf jeder Seite, also jede App, jedes Subsystem, alle Dienste, und es sind halt, wie bei euch ja auch wahrscheinlich, geht es schon so in die hunderte, wo man so Accounts hat, für was auch immer, und die sind alle generiert. Das heißt, ich verwende eigentlich fast nirgendswo mehr ein Passwort, an das ich mich selber erinnern könnte. Wenn ich mich selber gar nicht mehr daran erinnern kann, ist eigentlich der Begriff Passwort schon vollkommen wurscht. Das ist mehr so ein Secret-Krypto-Key, der da sozusagen ausgetauscht wird. Und ich entschlüssel eigentlich nur noch mein Schlüsselbund. Wenn man das jetzt halt so ein weiter spinnt, könnte man sozusagen auch diesen Austausch des Schlüssels, den ich ja offiziell immer noch eintippe, aber mittlerweile von einer Maschine in ein Feld füllen lasse, könnte man das eben auch gleich zu einem Protokoll machen. Sprich, man könnte sagen, das Anmelden geht nur noch über einen automatisierten Prozess mit einem Schlüsselkontrollsystem, was selber halt eine Keychain vorhält und die auf deinen Geräten auch entsprechend sichert. Aber es gibt niemals mehr so ein geschriebenes, gemerktes Passwort, was ich vielleicht auch noch selber mir ausdenken muss. Warum muss ich mir selber Passwörter ausdenken nach irgendwelchen bekloppten Regeln von so pizzaverseuchten Nerds, die irgendwie so in ihr Keller rum sitzen und irgendwie seit Monaten einfach die Sonne nicht mehr gesehen haben?
Was hast du von gegessen?
Wenn man auch gleich, also ich meine, wenn man sich sowieso schon mit ihrer Webseite unterhalten soll, wie ein Computer, na dann kann das doch bitte auch gleich der Computer machen. Und wenn ich mir halt so anschaue, wie ich jetzt mittlerweile auch die Sicherheit meiner Apps auf dem Telefon mit Touch ID benutze und eigentlich der Schlüssel zu allem in dieser Secure Enclave liegt, sozusagen in einem Krypto-Device, muss ich sagen, irgendwie gefällt mir das schon fast noch besser, weil ich könnte mir diese ganzen Krypto-Keys eh nicht mehr merken und irgendwie ist so diese Krypto-Wallet, die auf mich selber gekeyt ist, dann wahrscheinlich schon die bessere Wahl, oder? Jetzt hab ich natürlich der Biometrie das Wort geredet.
Naja, aber es muss ja nicht die Biometrie sein. Die Secure Enclave funktioniert ja auch ohne, dass du einen Fingerabdruck auf dem Phone festlegst. Also dein Sechs-Zeichen-Pin-Code ist ja auch das, was die Secure Enclave dann entlockt. Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass sie auf der Black Hat ist. Aber das Prinzip ist erstmal gut.
Vielleicht ist das der bessere Weg. Heute ist ja so was wie One Password, so ein Keychain-Manager oder die Funktion des Betriebssystems, die ich benutze seit es das gibt. Das ist ja den meisten Leuten gar nicht bewusst. Ich kenne auch gewieftere Computernutzer, die das schon verstanden haben, wie Computer funktionieren, die vielleicht auch programmieren, aber die sich so mit dem Konzept einer Keychain...
Die nutzen dann so Online-Sachen wie LastPass.
LastPass?
LastPass, ja, so ein Online-Passwort-Merker.
Oh, tolle Idee.
Genau, wurde auch gehackt.
Genau, wie sicher ist mein Password?
Die Leute haben sich sehr noch darüber gefreut. Yay, ich wurde informiert, dass ich mein Passwort ändern soll. Und warum solltest du es ändern? Weil es gehackt wurde.
Na ja, gut, es gibt ja noch die Möglichkeit, sich dann mit einem SSH-Key irgendwo anzumelden. Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine gute Alternative.
Ja, aber doch nicht für die Masse. Also ich rede jetzt wirklich von einem Pfad. Nicht so, was ist das nächste, was Nerds benutzen, sondern wie sichern wir die Systeme für alle? Also wie macht man diesen Zugang zu Systemen im Netz so sicher, aber auch gleichzeitig merkbar? Weil, also meine Hucke, wenn der jetzt irgendwie, wenn sein Brute Force jetzt immer noch rechnen würde, seit zwei Monaten kein Zugriff auf gar nichts, ich weiß nie, ob der noch lachen könnte.
Wie gesagt, das, also so die Online-Banking und so die ganz lebenswichtigen Sachen, die gingen schon alle zu resetten. Das, was mir dann eigentlich am Ende nur noch die größten Kopfschmerzen gemacht hat, war der Server-Access. Aber auch das hätte wahrscheinlich in mühsamer Arbeit geändert werden können.
Ja gut, aber es sind ja auch Daten und Sammlungen und Software, was man vielleicht nicht oft getappt hat und so.
Ja, absolut. Ich war schon sehr erleichtert, als das da stand. Ich kann's euch sagen. Ich war halt schon 2,5 Tage relativ geknickt und dann guck ich so in das Team Max rein und bin aufgesprungen und wollte nicht sofort gleich Alkohol ausschenken an die versammelte Kollegen-Kollegschaft. Wie sagt man? Belegschaft. Aber kurz davor.
Hier schreibt noch jemand, YubiKi hat mich jetzt auch nicht so richtig überzeugt. Hat mir mal zwar so ein Teil geschoppt, aber irgendwie ist das auch kacke.
Alles kacke, Ausstieg aus der Computertechnologie. Ich hab jetzt auch überlegt, ob ich einfach Segellehrer werde oder sowas. Und dann einfach so segeln die ganze Zeit. Ich denke mir sowieso beim Klimawandel und so Meeresspiegel steigen. Zukunftstechnologie-Boot. Irgendwann in Berlin am Fernsehturm festmachen. Wirklich, auch als ich diese Cloud-Provider-Webseite da letztens gelesen habe, ich dachte, das wird alles total schlimm. Dieses Internet of Things, alles wird eine totale Katastrophe. Ich sehe es schon kommen. Diese ganzen Node.js Apps, die in irgendwelche sinnlosen Devices reingeschraubt werden mit irgendwelchen Dependencies, die drei Jahre lang niemand angeguckt hat.
Das war ja auch mit diesen One-Liner-Dependencies.
Dieses Node.js, das werden wir nicht mehr los, oder? Da hat jemand diese merkwürdige Idee und jetzt hauen sie da irgendwie alle drauf.
War das Google?
Ja, also zumindest diese V8-Engine, die da drunter ist.
Die haben sie ja für ein Chrome gebaut. Die war ja jetzt erstmal nicht dafür da, dass man damit Server baut.
So fangen die Probleme an, dafür war es eigentlich nicht da.
Ja gut, auch JavaScript war nicht dafür da, dass man damit Server baut.
Gucken wir gerade, Node.js war das nicht... Ich dachte Ryan Dale und... Ach nee, von Joyend oder sowas kam das. Ist ja nicht verlinkt, der Ryan. Es wird einfach alles immer schlimmer. Was hat er hier? Irgendwas zum Segellehrer? Darfst du deine Kundschaft über Facebook einsammeln? Ach, wir haben einen Segel-Hitchhiker gehabt. Tatsächlich so ein Downhill-Skateboarder, der hat seine Fähre verpasst und kam dann bei uns am Boot vorbei und meinte so mit seinem Sack und Pack und seinem Skateboard, wo wir denn jetzt als nächstes hinfahren würden. Wir sind auch in seine Richtung gefahren und meinten, es ist halt ein Segelboot, fährt langsam. Also du könntest auch einfach auf die Fähre am Morgen warten, aber er wollte natürlich mit dem Segelboot mitfahren und das war auch sehr interessant. Da hat uns sehr viel Einblick in Downhill-Skateboarding gegeben und dann haben wir ihn natürlich gefragt, was ist die schnellste Geschwindigkeit, die du jemals gefahren hast mit so einem Downhill-Skateboard? Nee, einfach berg runter. Und was die machen...
Verdammt kurze Knotschzonen.
Und da waren auch Stürze in seinen Videos, die er uns da gezeigt hat. Was ich aber spektakulär fand, die benutzen halt auch ganz viele Drohnen, um so ihr Video-Footage zu machen. Und da hatten sie ein Video gemacht, das war sehr cool gemacht. Da gings so die Serpentinen links, rechts, also hattest du so voll im Bild. Und du siehst halt, wie die da so runterjagen. Und dann ist halt eine Drohne quasi die ganze Zeit, so ein Weitwinkelobjektiv, die Serpentinen, sozusagen einfach gerade vorne mit runtergefahren. Das heißt, du hattest irgendwie die Verfolgerkamera, die Serpentinen die ganze Zeit, und du hattest immer diese Totale von der Drohne, die irgendwie einfach nur senkrecht runtergeht. Dann hatten sie auch manche Videos, wo die Drohne quasi hinterherfliegt, wo so ein Typ halt einfach den Leuten möglichst spektakulär mit so einer Drohne hinterherjagt. Das waren echt ganz coole Videos. Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich... Ich bin Facebook-Freund jetzt mit ihm. Könnte ich jetzt vielleicht mal noch ein Video hier von seiner Facebook-Page kratzen und in den Chat geben.
So, jetzt haben wir noch irgendwie 20 Minuten. Jetzt gehen wir nochmal den Talking-Stick rum. Wer hat am wenigsten erzählt? Dennis und Letty.
Wieso? Das müssen wir kurz überlegen. Was haben wir denn hier noch auf der Liste?
Wir haben noch berufliche Weiterentwicklung.
Berufliche Umorientierung, Weiterentwicklung.
Kannst du äußern oder nicht?
Ich bin wieder zurück in das akademische Umfeld gewechselt.
Ja, raus aus dem Verlagen.
Oh Gott, ich hab's schon wieder fast vergessen. Ja, genau, raus aus den Verlagen, rein in die Microsoft-Welt. Nein, so schlimm ist es nicht. Aber ich hab in der Fachhochschule in Potsdam angefangen als wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin und sitze jetzt gerade auf einem Forschungsprojekt, was relativ kurz leider ist.
Also zeitlich kurz.
Zeitlich kurz, genau. Bin danach auch so noch am Fachbereich angestellt. Und es ist irgendwie ganz schön, wenn man so aus der Wirtschaft kommt und diese Zwänge von irgendwelchen nervigen Kunden hat, die dir mit irgendwelchem Scheiß in den Ohren liegen, gerade wenn du Visualisierung machst, und die so mit ihren semispannenden Daten um die Ecke gejagt kommen. Dann sind sie so, hoho, hier, spannend, voll das Ding. Es ist schön, jetzt mal wieder Freiheit zu haben, rumzuprobieren. Und wie Roddy eben erwähnt hatte, plage ich mich gerade mit Datenbanken rum. Postgres ist ja irgendwie ganz süß und umgänglich. Aber das mit dem Microsoft, das muss ich mir noch überlegen.
Mit dem SQL-Server.
Das wurde dir jetzt nur so auf den Tisch geknallt, du musst ja jetzt irgendwie gerade mit klarkommen oder was?
Nee, nee, also eigentlich war da sogar mal eine Abmachung. Wir bekommen Datenbankzugang im Sinne von einer API, die wir benutzen. Aber bei dem einen Server hat das irgendwie nicht geklappt oder es ist denen zu heikel. Also unserem Forschungspartner.
Dann machen sie eine SQL-Kopie und dann hier.
Dann kriegt man halt einen Damp und hier kümmert euch.
Damp ist irgendwie auch echt das falsche Wort, finde ich. Manchmal ist es wirklich einfach nur so ein Damp.
Einmal alles ausgekackt.
Ja, ich finde das trifft sich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es auch in vielen Fällen einfach so. Aber immer wenn ich dieses Wort höre, denke ich mir so, nein, kack mir jetzt nicht, da ist einfach auf die Festplatte.
Ja, es ist ja das, was passiert.
Ja, es endet in einem kleinen gepackten Häufchen. Ja, was stinkt? Das aktuelle Projekt ist weniger Visualisierung. Es ist eher so ein bisschen verfügbar machen von Daten, die in der Datenbank sind. Mehr so Interfacesign wird das werden. Also denke ich, dass es für mich mehr Interface-Forschungsfragen sind, wie man so Daten verfügbar machen kann in der Datenbank. Wie kann man die Daten schon während der Abfrage sichtbar machen? Dass man halt so den Nutzer nicht so ins Leere laufen lässt bei einer Datenbankabfrage oder bei einer bestimmten Aufgabe, die er halt einfach so zu erledigen hat. Das ist so der Hauptpunkt gerade, Daten wirklich zugänglich zu machen. Also wir reden halt von Forschungsdatenbanken gerade. Genau, und da bin ich die Entwicklerin in dem Team. Das sind eben zwei Designern. Es ist total spannend, wieder mal so ein Projekt von Null anzugehen und wirklich so mit Interviews mit den Leuten anzufangen, was sie so für einen Workflow haben und was sich daraus so für Fragen ergeben und welche Probleme die so mit einem System haben und das so zu analysieren. Und anhand dessen dann auch zu überlegen, wie man das System neu gestaltet, neue Anwendungen schafft.
Sind die Leute denn kluge Anwender? Entschuldigung, das ist nicht das richtige Wort. Sind die Leute in ihrer Tätigkeit oder in ihrem Daten, in ihrem Visualisierungswunsch gut trainiert?
Nein, teilweise nicht. Also du hast zwei Anwender. Einmal so den Anwender, der so der Gelegenheitsanwender ist. Der vielleicht nur ganz einfache Sachen mit dem System bisher macht. Also wirklich so, gib mir mal Feld A aus der Datenbank. So ganz ganz grob gesagt. Der hat so eine Aufgabe und da weiß er jetzt gerade, welche Knöpfe er drückt, damit er so zu seinem Ziel kommt. Und dann haben wir aber noch den Anwender, der komplexere Anfragen dann bearbeitet. Also wir haben halt zwei Leute eigentlich. So im Prinzip zwei Usergruppen, kann man sagen. Experte, der wirklich die Daten komplett kennt, der das komplette Hinterwissen hat, wo er was findet derzeit an dieser sehr versteckten Benutzeroberfläche.
Was für Daten das jetzt sind, kannst du jetzt nicht sagen?
Das weiß ich echt gesagt gerade gar nicht. Habe ich mir gerade überlegt, das weiß ich nicht.
Kategorie? Forschungsdaten, klingt immer so.
Ah nee, das eine, ich glaube, das kann man schon sagen, das eine sind die Daten, die zu Förderprogrammen von Deutschland, Ländern, Ländern in Deutschland und EU so ein bisschen ausgeschrieben werden, worauf man sich eben bewerben kann. Das sind die einen Daten, wo ich sag mal schon relativ klar ist, was so in der Datenbank und in der Datenstelle dahinter steckt. Und das andere ist mehr schon Richtung Geoinformations, so Minigeoinformationssystem, was dahinter ist, wo es um Länderprofile geht, also so zum Beispiel Berlin oder Brandenburg und so ein kleines kleine Landkreis in Brandenburg, wie der so zum Beispiel wirtschaftlich aufgestellt ist, wie die Förderlandschaft da so aussieht.
Das sind zwei separate Sachen?
Das sind zwei separate Sachen und die könnte man zusammen denken, muss man aber nicht. Und wir fangen erstmal damit an, dass man die so ein bisschen getrennt sieht. Aber ich meine, in einem Interface wird dir vielleicht auch nicht so richtig ersichtlich, ob es da eine Grenze gerade gibt.
Vor allem ist ja auch immer die Frage, welche Kreativität legen die Leute an den Tag, überhaupt auf bombige Fragenstellungen zu kommen.
Also ich glaube, wenn man die Leute direkt fragt, die würden gerne schon dieses Thema irgendwie zusammen haben, weil sie auch den Sinn davon sehen.
Unabhängig von der Fahrrad, wenn man jetzt mal vielleicht nur bei Förderantragsdaten so, also wir reden jetzt quasi so von der Datenbank, die mir quasi so, das sind alle Förderungsoptionen, die es so gibt, wo man irgendwie Geld beantragen kann und wenn man auf den richtigen Knopf drückt, dann kommt unten Geld raus, wie wir so ein Geldautomaten. Und nehmen wir mal an, die Leute, die da jetzt an die Datenbank rangehen, haben den Wunsch, für sich oder einen Klienten das bestmögliche Ding zu finden.
Das ist nicht so der richtige, also diejenigen, die die Datenbank bedienen, sind nicht so die Leute, die die Nutzen dieser Datenbank sind. Politik ist die Zielgruppe der Datenbank. Politiker nehmen Teile aus der Datenbank, um damit Diskussionen zu führen oder Besuche in irgendwelchen Wahlkampfreden zu halten. Die wollen damit mehrere Sachen machen. Allen ist noch nicht so richtig bewusst, was sie da eigentlich für Daten haben und was man damit noch alles so machen kann, außer das, was gerade passiert. Es kommt jemand zu mir und möchte Informationen, also Politiker kommt zu mir und möchte Informationen, zum Beispiel über seinen Wahlkreis, ist derzeit das höhere Nutzungsszenario. Das größere.
Das ist ja mehr im Sinne, ich bilde mich über, was es gibt, damit ich schlau da herreden kann. Das ist ja ein bisschen unspannend.
Genau, das dachte ich am Anfang auch. Langsam wird es spannender. Das ist auch für mich programmiert technisch. Wenn man wieder mal ganz alleine ein Projekt macht, muss man sich ja schon zur Datenbank anwenden, einen kleinen Server-Struktur.
Was ist denn dann die Motivation des Abfragenden? Was weiß man denn danach, nach einer erfolgreichen Abfrage, was man vorher nicht wusste?
Na zum Beispiel, wie ist die arbeitslose Struktur in einem Gebiet? Und wie verhält sich vielleicht die arbeitslose Struktur zu...
Okay, das ist jetzt die zweite Datenbank. Ich war jetzt gerade noch bei den Förderanträgen. Mit Struktureninformationen, okay, das sehe ich voll ein. Da muss man irgendwie im Bilde sein. Aber wenn man jetzt so einen Fördertöpfer hat, ist ja jetzt, sagen wir mal, so eine politische Wissensauskunft wahrscheinlich...
Man kann dann eher so Bedürfnisse ermitteln. Also wo gibt es noch freie Sachen, die man fördern könnte? Oder man würde halt zum Beispiel auch sehen können, wie sich zum Beispiel ein Bundesland ausrichtet. Also es hat halt erst das gefördert. Und dann hat es aber gemerkt, ups, wir haben da irgendwas verschlafen, was eigentlich total wichtig ist im Förderbereich, da mal ein bisschen Geld in die Hand zu nehmen und sichere Passwörter zum Beispiel mal zu erforschen. Was ist der geeignete Weg? Und das könnte man damit dann so ein bisschen aufschlüsseln auch. Also dass man so einen Verlauf sieht, wie ist die Entwicklung in einer Region gewesen. Und gibt es halt auch einen Bruch da drin? Also wurde halt irgendwas nicht mehr gefördert und dann wurde es weiter gefördert? Oder was anderes gefördert?
Dein Splin ist ja jetzt im Prinzip das User Interface. Und damit oder sozusagen, vielleicht ist das User Interface nicht die richtige Bezeichnung.
Ja, es wird so ein bisschen auf Mini-Visualisierungen im Interface ja auch dann hinauslaufen, was ich ja super spannend finde. Wenn du verschiedene Ansichten auf Daten hast, also hast du halt ein Interface und hast aber so verschiedene kleine Mini-Visualisierungen, um durch die Daten zu interagieren. Das finde ich halt super spannend, so kleine verbundene Visualisierungen. Nein, nenn es nicht Apps, nenn es... Kleine Pikachu, auf denen man rumklicken kann und die dann die Farbe ändern.
Genau, so Augmented Reality in eine Förderungsantrags-Datenbank.
Ich hab mir schon die ganze Zeit überlegt, was kann man so Lustiges da reinbauen? Und wir sind irgendwie teilweise immer so auf Clippy zurückgekommen. Aber vielleicht ist so ein Pokeball viel cooler.
Ich denke die ganze Zeit so in die Richtung, also wenn ich jetzt potenzieller Antragsteller wäre. So, sagen wir mal, ich wähl jetzt ein mittelständisches Unternehmen mit latenter technologischer Kompetenz in irgendeinem Bereich.
Das kann ja sein.
Das kann bei mir nicht sein, weil das für mich zu faul. Aber sowas kann man sich ja irgendwie vorstellen. Und die Unternehmen wollen natürlich einen möglichst guten Match haben auf sich und auf potenzielle Förderanträge. Dazu muss man ja dann überhaupt auch erstmal drauf kommen, was sind überhaupt Parameter, die man überhaupt abfragen wollen würde und damit auch vergleichen wollen würde. Dazu müsste man ja irgendwie so ein bisschen spielerisch immer wieder Vergleichsszenarien heranziehen. Also man muss sozusagen, ich frage mich gerade, ob das Ziel des Forschens an einem User-Interface in solchen Fällen vielleicht primär sich in die Richtung entwickeln sollte, dass es versucht, Beispiele zu liefern, um einen in so einen kreativen Suchmodus zu bringen, wofür es dann natürlich auch immer noch ein brauchbares Interface gibt, aber wo man dann so Building-Blocks quasi sich zusammensammeln kann. Über diese Blickrichtung kannst du dir das und das anschauen, über diese Blickrichtung kannst du das und das anschauen. Dann sammel ich mir diese ganzen Blickrichtungen zusammen und vereinige sie sozusagen in so einem View und dann erklärt er mir auch, warum das denn sozusagen zu meinen Daten, die ich dann auch noch mit eingebe, dann irgendwie passt.
Der Ansatz, mit dem eine Nutzer auch so ein bisschen durch das System zu führen und Hilfestellungen zu geben, ist nicht nur für den Antragsteller, der glaube ich primär wirklich gerade nicht so die Zielgruppe von denen ist, was eigentlich komisch ist. Kann man vielleicht noch ein bisschen herausdefinieren, dass sie es halt auch ein bisschen mehr promoten nach draußen. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Aber genau diese Führung, wie man mit dem System gut interagieren kann, um zu etwas zu gelangen, ist auch jetzt bei den derzeitigen Usern schon so, dass sie sich das teilweise so ein bisschen mehr wünschen oder einfach ein bisschen mehr sehen wollen. Also das haben wir halt auch so ein bisschen mit auf dem Schirm, definitiv. Aber was dabei rauskommt, das Projekt hat gerade erst angefangen. Wir haben einige coole Ideen schon. Erst mal gerade noch auf Papier und ich bau halt gerade so ein bisschen Backendsachen.
Was da für Folgeanträge kommen wirst, das weiß man jetzt ja noch nicht. Aber wirst ja irgendwie Professorin dann irgendwann.
Naja, erstmal überlegen wir uns das mit der Doktorarbeit mal noch. Und dann können wir größer denken. Ja dann möchte ich aber bitte Letti de Bauski als Künstlernamen haben. Dann können wir darüber sprechen, nur dieses Kriterium.
Gute Motivation.
Nein, aber auf jeden Fall will ich da erstmal ein bisschen bleiben und mich austoben. Also weil ich es halt gerade cool finde, einfach diese Freiheit zu haben, Sachen auszuprobieren, die mir halt auch so bei Visualisierungsfragen gerade noch so immer mal wieder im Kopf rumgegeistert sind. Und Frage für Programmiersprache ist da halt, finde ich, auch fürs Backend nicht uns unwesentlich. Weil man halt so grad so auf Datenaufarbeitung auf dem Server noch mal da so ein bisschen das im Kopf hat. Also ist halt JavaScript irgendwie auch nicht so toll, wenn du irgendwelche Berechnungen noch vielleicht anstellen musst.
Machst da Python stattdessen?
Ja, für Berechnungen vielleicht gar nicht.
Ich hab mich jetzt noch nicht so richtig...
Na, da gibt es zumindest hier SciPy und wie sie nicht alle heißen.
Interessantes Thema übrigens, weil ich auch gerade mich mal neu mit Python beschäftigen muss, nachdem ich bisher eigentlich... Was hab ich gemacht mit Python? Ich hab ja mal ein Buch über Python durchgelesen. Weil ich wollte wissen, ob mir die Sprache gefällt und hab mir das dann irgendwie relativ ausführlich durchgelesen, weiß gerade gar nicht mehr genau welches. Und gefiel mir nicht. Das wird natürlich jetzt viele Hörer in Abgründe stürzen und so weiter. Ich kann es auch gar nicht so richtig festmachen. Ich hätte schon so zwei, drei kleine nitty-pitty, nitpicky Dinge, die am Ende wahrscheinlich gar nicht so wichtig sind. Aber richtig nützliche Sachen gehen ja auch so schnell nicht weg. Das hat man ja zum Beispiel in diesem Batch gesehen. Und wo ich Python nach wie vor für eine wirklich gute Sache finde, ist Programmieren lernen. Ich finde, dass das sozusagen als Basis, als Musikersatz ist. Es ist eine Sprache, die ziemlich viele ordentliche Konzepte enthält.
Die üblichen halt.
Was da mit deinem Mikrofon schon wieder passiert?
Ist das abgehauen?
Also für unterschiedliche Geschmacksrichtungen von üblich ist da einiges drin. Wenn man es kann, also wenn man Python mal erlernt hat in seinem Leben, so dass man so proficient ist, ist das nicht unpraktisch, weil damit kann man viele sinnvolle Sachen machen. Also es ist einfach eine ordentliche administrative Sprache, um seinen Scheiß automatisiert zu bekommen auf allen erdenklichen Systemen. Und da sicherlich eine bessere Wahl als Pearl oder Shell oder PHP, ja.
Ist ja auch Teil von TensorFlow.
Und diesem AI-Teil da von Google oder was? Ja klar, weil das ist halt so unten als Glue-Sprache, ist es halt einfach extrem verbreitet und meiner Meinung nach auch total sinnvoll. Und vor allem ist es halt auch mit so diesen, was ich auch sehr schätze, ist, dass es in der Python-Welt sehr viel unheimlich gut abgehangene Bibliotheken gibt.
Wenn Sie sich nicht nur mit Ihrem Python 2 und 3 irgendwie da zerstreiten würden und das irgendwie zweigleisig waren. Naja, es gibt halt beide Versionen und irgendwie baust du für 2, geht es nicht auf 3 und andersrum und gewisse Frameworks gibt es auf 3 noch nicht, weil sie immer noch nicht geportet haben.
Das ist mir auch schon oft passiert, dass man in diese Falle rein rennt.
Also ich hab meinen Webservices damit gebaut, Google App Engine mit Python und das war ganz okay, bis auf dieses Daytime-Objekt, das ist halt ein Drain-Rack. Also da müssen Sie mal was machen, was bringen, was irgendwie funktioniert.
Ja, aber ich muss sagen, Python ist halt, also ich finde das nicht so ähnlich, aus ähnlichen Gründen, warum ich Ruby jetzt nicht als die ideale Backend-Sprache sehen würde. Also es ist halt okay für, wenn man seinen eigenen Kram halt irgendwie, und man braucht nicht mehr als Screen Threads und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist halt jetzt auch nicht die wuppigste Sprache von allen sozusagen, oder runtime. Insofern, wenn man halt irgendwie wenig Nutzer hat und halt irgendwie so, einfach sich durch Daten graben will, zum Beispiel, da sind sowieso die dynamischen Script-Sprachen ja eh immer ganz handlich für, ist das alles gut, aber wie gesagt, ähnlich wie Ruby selbst, ist halt auch so eine Sprache, die jetzt zum Beispiel für so reines Backend nicht unbedingt redistiniert ist.
Gut, die Performance war nicht so toll, aber einfach mal, wenn du so einen Service baust und hast halt dann Anfragen aus verschiedenen Zeitzonen und dann willst du das irgendwie in Griff kriegen, das war halt, das ging halt irgendwie.
Ich finde aber auch generell, dass Zeitzonenmanagement ist in dieser Liste von Cash Invalidation in Naming Things, Timezones sollte damit drauf sein.
Ja, also wenn es Apple mit Ennis Date und Ennis Kalender und so weiter nicht einmal ordentlich implementiert hätte und du weißt, man kann das richtig machen, also es gibt ein Framework, das kann das und es kann das sehr, sehr gut, dann ist es kein Excuses, Leute haben es hingekriegt.
Der war leider auf der falschen Plattform, in dem Fall.
Im Chat hat er gerade diesen Computer-File-Dingens gepaustet, das Video würde ich auf jeden Fall zu dem Thema mal angucken, das ist sau geil, weil er hat es wirklich irgendwie, also selber den Scheiß programmieren, nein, abgehängt, hangendes Framework benutzen, das kann.
Ja, aber wenn du es nicht hast, dann hast du es halt nicht, ne?
Ja, dann nimmst du eine andere Sprache, also wenn du mit Zeiten umgehen musst und mit Zeitzonen und es gibt in der Sprache kein Framework, die das kann, dann bist du auf der falschen Sprache unterwegs.
Aber ich finde, selbst wenn deine Sprache das kann, gibt es genug andere Probleme mit Zeitzonen, die du dir in deiner Business-Logic trotzdem noch einhandeln kannst. Also Zeitzone ist aus meiner Erfahrung ähnlich toll für Weihwasser etc. wie Naming Things on Cash Invalidation.
Find ich nicht.
Also ich hab dir ja eigentlich gerade über Python reden. Also ich verstehe euer Schmerz. Da fällt mir dann auch mal wieder dieses schöne Zitat von Steve Jobs ein, als er sich irgendwie zum Thema Y2K geäußert hat. Erinnert ihr euch da noch dran?
War es dunkel nur?
Ja, er meinte irgendwie. Was man jetzt so von Kobol und so weiter jetzt nicht unbedingt hätte sagen können. Aber warum ich das mit den Peißen angeschnitten habe, ich hatte vorhin ja schon einen kurzen Exkurs mit diesem Badge. Das hat mich sozusagen, also dieser Badge hat dann auch induziert, dass mein Sohn dann seine nächste Stufe von ich will programmieren lernen gezündet hat. So und als er dann diesen Badge in der Hand hatte und dann ich ihm gesagt habe, da kann man dann mit Python drauf programmieren, hat er mich dann sozusagen endlich erhört und ist irgendwie bereit, jetzt von seinen Scratch-Experimenten dann irgendwie auf Python zu wechseln. So und dann sitzt er da so als Dad und überlegt sich so, oh Mann, mein Sohn will programmieren, lernen und jetzt geht's irgendwie ein gemacht, aber jetzt kommt sozusagen richtige Programmier-Sprachen ins Spiel und nicht immer nur dieses irgendwelches Breitsfliegen über den Bildschirm und tun Dinge miteinander. So und dann muss ich dann erstmal so ein bisschen mein Python-Wissen überhaupt erst mal so reaktivieren, weil ich bin jetzt nicht so, ich bin jetzt nicht Python-Flood oder so, ich kann mir das so angucken und weiß nicht etwa, was das Programm so tut, aber weiß ja, wie das ist, wenn man so tippt, dann muss ja dann auch jedes Zeichen stimmen und brauche jetzt hier einen Doppelpunkt oder ein Simkone oder gar nichts und wie viel Leerzeichen muss man jetzt irgendwie einrücken und wie genau, wie hart ist das System sozusagen damit und so. Gut, das kriegt man dann irgendwie alles noch so halbwegs gebacken, aber dann versuchst du natürlich auch erstmal was zu finden, was dann auch das Interesse weckt, weil du kannst ja dann nicht irgendwie sofort mit, naja, du kannst dich dann hier irgendwie über die USB-serielle irgendwie in der Command-Line da auf deinem Batch einloggen und dann hast du da irgendwie verschiedene APIs für deine LED und so. Ist nicht so ganz so der Moment, wo du sozusagen einsteigst. Also da will man natürlich dann irgendwie relativ schnell hin. Und was hab ich dann ausgegraben?
Logo?
Ja, nicht Logo, sondern ein Pythoner. Es gibt dann einfach eine Turtle Library. So und das führt auch im Jahre 2016 immer noch totaler Begeisterung. Dieses einfache Ich erlerne, dass Das Swift Playground ist ja auch so was.
Dieses Vieh in 3D, das ist ja mehr oder weniger auch die Schildkröte.
Genau, das ist so ein bisschen so Logo und Steeroyds. Das ist so der nächste Schritt, dass man einfach solche Highly Interactive Environments hat. Und dann hab ich so ein bisschen geguckt, ob es irgendwie so gute Learning Python für Kids gibt. Und da bin ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt für alle Tipps dankbar, falls das jemand hört. Problem ist, dass so viele Learning Python-Dinger doch irgendwie dann schon auf Seite 2 einfach so mega nerdy einsteigen. Also meistens ist es ja auch so, die allermeisten Programmiertutorials sind ja so, du weißt schon, was Programmieren ist und jetzt erkläre ich dir, wie das in Python ist. Was okay ist, wenn man schon programmieren kann. Weil es spart ja auch eine Menge Zeit. Aber dieses deine erste Sprache ist Python oder deine erste Sprache, die du so in dieser Art wie Python ist, die du erlernst, was auch Ruby sein könnte, was auch... Also all die Sprachen, wo man so ich tippe alles in einen Texteditor ein und ich brauch dafür ein Environment. Dann startest du von diesem Python 3, dann gibt's dann dieses komische Idle und dann ist das irgendwie so TK-Rot und weißt du, wo dann irgendwie sich nichts mehr so richtig verhält wie die anderen Programme auf deinem Computer. Gut, kann man irgendwie alles benutzen, aber ist halt alles schwierig. Dann hab ich auf dem iPad geguckt, da ist auch alles genauso schwierig, was ich entdeckt habe. Aber das wär ganz gut, wenn man da irgendwie was findet. Und was auch ganz hilfreich wäre, sind so Strategien, spannende Sachen, wo man auch so Kids gut mitreißen kann. Also so gute Ideen für überschaubar komplexe Aufgaben, die man so auch ganz gut skaliert bekommt, woran man dann eben Schritt für Schritt auch wirklich die richtigen Konzepte hat. Ich traue mir das am Ende auch alles zu, das dynamisch und ad hoc und so weiter zu machen, aber manchmal gibt es ja dann vielleicht auch so einen Teil, wo man sagen kann, hier auf dem iPad, da kannst du irgendwie Instructions holen, Inspirationen holen, Schritt für Schritt.
Hast du mit dem Juniore schon Human Resource Maschinen gespielt?
Kann dieses Batch GPS?
Hat aber einen Accelerator drin.
Weil so ein GPS mit handlicher Python-RP zum Abfragen, da könnte man glaube ich, wir sind im Pokemon Go, da bist du glaube ich ganz schnell bei irgendwelchen Schatzsuche, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, für Projekte, die dann mit Realität, Interaktion und so.
Man kann sich natürlich hacken mit einem Dolphi-Scanner oder so.
Also hier, der Chat ist jetzt gerade voll mit Vorschlägen, die musst du dir halt alle mal durchgucken. Musst du mal scrollen.
Kauf dir mal einen Computer, der scrollen kann.
Okay, da kann man sich alles anschauen. Ich weiß nicht, so Human Resource Machine. Diese Low-Level-Sachen.
Das ist sozusagen komplett unabhängig von der Programmiersprache. Das ist genau das, was du brauchst, wenn du so ein Buch mal in die Hand kriegst, dass du schon so ein bisschen verstanden hast.
Aber die Kurve in dem Spiel ist halt auch sehr steil. Dann ganz schnell.
Der braucht halt aber auch für die ersten Level viel länger, die wir halt schnell und sofort machen. Das heißt, der hat seinen Lernteil am Anfang, wo wir noch die Einführung machen.
Ja, also solche... Da hatten wir ja schon mal drüber gesprochen. Da gab es ja schon vorher so ein paar einfache Dinge, die auch so ähnlich funktionieren wie dieser Swift Playground, da mit dem kleinen Roboter, der durch den Gegend läuft und so weiter. Das hat alles schon durch. DOS ist nicht so das Problem. So was gibt es hier. Teach your kids to code in Python. Mit Leuten...
In Mikrofonen sprechen.
Dr. Bryson Payne. Parent-Friendly Guide to Python Programming. So so, parent-friendly. Ich wollte ja jetzt kein Buch lesen. Ich wollte irgendwas haben. Also ich will ja kein Buch lesen. Ich will ja einfach was haben, was für... Also es gibt so ein Buch, das haben wir auch gerade. Müssen wir mal gucken, wie erfolgreich wir damit sind. Aber du musst das ja dann immer auch in so ein Environment kriegen und die Kids erst mal in so einen Prozess reinkriegen. Wie speichere ich Dateien?
Eigentlich wäre... Eigentlich wäre, stelle ich mir so vor, ein was cool, was... Sag mal, du hast schon so ein Grundspiel, sag mal, du hättest sowas wie Minecraft, ja? Wo du aber sozusagen, sag mal, eine Python-Appi hättest, um das Ganze... Um diese ganze...
Ist eine Python-Appi für Minecraft?
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich sage jetzt mal, was ich mir so vorstellen könnte, was halt geil ist, wo du sowieso schon, du hast schon was und es ist aber relativ so plain, ja? Und sozusagen, um jetzt in der Welt da weiterzukommen, musst du dann eben so kleine Schnipsel-Coat dir da zusammen basteln und du siehst halt dann die Repräsentanz in der Welt und kannst dann vielleicht damit interagieren und so weiter und das wäre eigentlich ganz cool. Wenn du schon was Funktionierendes hast und dann merkst, ah, wenn ich jetzt hier den Coat anfasse und schnalle, wie das dahinter funktioniert, dann kann ich die Welt nochmal quasi ganz anders anfassen, wie es hier in der Realität auch ist. Wenn man so einen Computer vor sich hat und weiß, wie das mit dem Programmieren funktioniert, dann kann man da ganz andere Sachen mitmachen. Also ich mein, ja, da ist halt in Anführungsstrichen das Blöde, dass du zwar mit Redstone ja auch so eigentlich ein ganz mächtiges Konstrukt hast, um verrückte Dinge zu machen, allerdings das so Low Level vom Konzept her ist, dass ja, du dann halt auch anfängst mit Logic Gates und so weiter gleich und ich mein, wer weiß, vielleicht ist das auch geil für die Kids, wenn sie da mit einsteigen, aber nicht unbedingt das Zugänglichste vielleicht. Hier, guck mal, es gibt ein Minecraft-Mod namens Computercraft, aber das ist Lure und nicht wirklich eine API für das Spiel. Weil wir uns ja hier so in der Endschwingung befinden, wollte ich hier noch eine Sache in den Chat mal posten, ein Diagramm, was ich gefunden habe, der Emerging Technology Hype Cycle for 2016. Hast du auch gesehen?
Hab ich gesehen, ja, ich liebe ja diese Gardner Hype Cycles, die hauen ja schon in gewisser Hinsicht hin. Immer ganz interessant gewesen, das hier auf den aktuellen Technologiequatsch gemapped zu sehen.
Ja, und ich fand das halt auch so, also du hast diese ganzen Begriffe und so weiter, du hast es gehört und auch so diese...
Wir müssen erstmal erklären, der Gardner Hype Cycle ist so die Aussage, dass eigentlich alles, also normalerweise bezieht es der Hype Cycle ja auf ein Thema. In diesem Fall...
Ist ja auch, also so Augmented Reality, Virtual Reality, Machine Learning, also ist schon ein bisschen gemischt, aber...
Ja, so derzeit, so der ganze Mumpitz mit was... Emerging Technology, also was jetzt sozusagen gerade kommt und wo man immer so viel Versprechen drin ist. Und dann der Gardener Hype Cycle sagt halt, es gibt dann erstmal so diesen... So was geht los, der Innovation Trigger, dann kommt Peak of Inflated Expectations, so. Und dann... Dann geht's also wieder sozusagen bergab. Also erst so ein riesiger Hype, dann ab in den Keller, aber nicht ganz so tief wie das, wo man hergekommen ist. Und dann so eine flach ansteigende Kurve mit Slope of Enlightenment, wo man dann sieht so, ah ja, jetzt...
Jetzt kommt's, ne? Wir haben uns auf den gemeinsamen Nenner geeinigt, was jetzt wirklich eigentlich machbar ist und vielleicht sinnvoll oder umsetzbar und ja.
Aber es sieht doch ganz gut aus.
Aber hier sind verschiedene Dinge so vermischt, das find ich so ein bisschen...
Na, ich fand's... ja, ich fand's trotzdem interessant, weil so diese Phasen und die Begriffe da doch irgendwie ganz gut gepasst haben.
Naja, was passt denn da deiner Meinung nach?
Na, Machine Learning ist hier topplatz, ganz oben ist gerade der Ultrahype.
Ja, aber womit geht's denn hier los? Smart, Dust, 4D, Print?
Ja, das ist ganz unten. Aber hier Commercial Drones oder Internet of Things Plattform, dem sie noch 5 bis 10 Jahre geben. Mitten im Innovation Trigger.
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich, wie das gemeint ist. Das ist sozusagen für die einzelnen Themen, wo die sich gerade in dem Cycle befinden.
Genau. Und Smart Dust ist noch nicht mal wirklich getriggert. 4D Printing, was auch immer das sein soll.
Wär auch mal gespannt, was das werden könnte.
Ist auf jeden Fall noch vor dem Peak auf Inflated Expectations.
Aber das meine ich halt genau, also auch gerade dieses Machine Learning und Artificial Intelligence, was ja noch nicht Artificial Intelligence ist, wie wir das hier vor einer Weile auch mal besprochen haben, sondern dieser Begriff der Wabert halt jetzt auch so durch die Buzzword-Bingo-Zentralen der Welt. Und alle haben so gerade, oh ja, wir schmeißen da ganz viel Daten hin und dann lassen wir da so Algorithmen drüber laufen und das wird irgendwie uns ermöglichen, so Leapfrogging ahead of the competition und was, man darf nicht so alles so...
Weil die anderen das ja nicht machen, ne?
Genau, und dann kommt halt am Ende raus, ah, wir haben jetzt rausgefunden, dass wenn wir jetzt den Button weiter rechts machen, dann kriegen wir 3,4% bessere Verkaufsraten.
Du willst heute noch King of Buzzword werden, oder?
Ja, ja, hier, pass auf, ich hab den perfekten Abschluss-Tweet von meinem Lieblings-Twitter-Account der letzten Wochen und Monate. Der Twitter-Account heißt SadServer. Der hat einfach hin und wieder... SadServer, also der hat auch Tweets, die sind jetzt nicht so der Mega-Brüller, aber es sind immer wieder absolute Perlen dabei. Und der letzte Tweet, der passt zu diesem Abzehrer, oder was ich vorhin gepostet hatte, klickt mal hier kurz nochmal im Schlag. Das war so die Begriffserklärung Clown Computing. Overcomplicating an architecture to save money, which ends up more costly than a simpler alternative. Also hat es einfach so richtig schön auf den Punkt gebracht. Und dieser Twitter-Account hat oft, so ähnlich wie Security Taylor Swift oder Swift on Security, genau so hat er auch wirklich ganz großartige, also das ist eine Twitter-Follow-Recommendation. Wenn es noch nicht auf seinen Kreatoren gewechselt ist, ist es Maschinellehrung. Großartig.
So, haben wir noch irgendwelche praktischen Hinweise? Also Freak Show ist jetzt auf jeden Fall wieder da.
Back in the Hood.
Und wir gehen jetzt mal wieder so auf den coolen zwei Wochenrhythmus wieder.
Nächste Woche ist wann? Ist das am Dienstag, dieser Apple-Termin?
Da haben wir jetzt klug gelegt, ne? Wir lassen uns mal wieder eine Woche Zeit und durchatmen. Ich habe übrigens gerade schon ausreichend hier aus den Fotos der Rumorsides herausgelesen, dass es wohl tatsächlich auf so ein komisches Lightning-Headset hinausläuft. Und ich glaube, ich sollte mir einfach das ganze Prediction-Business komplett sparen. Ich bin raus. Früher habe ich ja irgendwie noch alle Moves zwei Jahre vorher vorausgesagt, aber schon an der Watch bin ich gescheitert. Und jetzt auch noch das.
Aber dann nächsten Mittwoch, einen Tag nach der Vorstellung, was du machst, wird doch gar nicht so verkehrt.
Doch, das ist immer verkehrt, weil erstens ist es ja am Mittwoch. Das heißt, unsere Sendung wäre parallel oder würde am Dienstag?
Der siebteste Mittwoch. Ich habe auch nochmal nachgeguckt.
Haben die das nicht traditionell immer Dienstag gemacht?
Ja, aber jetzt machen sie es traditionell am Mittwoch.
Die wissen auch nicht mehr, was gut ist.
Die werden schon irgendwelche Gründe haben.
Ja, weil unsere Sendung da ist und sie...
Nein, das ist irgendwie mit Labor Day und du hast es nicht gesehen. Ich finde, ehrlich gesagt, unseren Ansatz da erst mal eine Woche den Herzkast zu sacken lassen und so. Und dann auch mit so ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen schauen, Informationen dazu kommentieren, ist jetzt deutlich sinnvoller, als da so einen total hyperbolischen, hektischen, ich kommentiere, am schnellsten Modus reinzugehen. Aber wir werden es natürlich des Themas annehmen.
Nein, dann müssen wir es Fans und so überlassen.
Wobei, das ist ja immer noch nicht die Keynote, die mich irgendwie groß... Also ich meine, das iPhone 7...
Ja, weißt du es?
Was weiß ich?
Ob das die Keynote, die dich großartig? Vielleicht ist es ja doch die Keynote.
Da kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen, dass sie mich nicht weiter tangiert.
Na dann werden wir mal gucken, was da kommt.
Na dann kommen halt neue iPhones in Tablettgröße. Das krieg ich mir in die Hosentasche.
Butterstullen.
Mich können sie mit ihrem iPhone SE 2 können sie mich irgendwie wieder anrufen, wenn es soweit ist.
Anrufen, ja.
Das 7 SE.
Ja, 7 SE, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, jetzt haben sie ja dieses...
iPhone SE für alte Säcke mit 300mm Klick.
Ich mach jetzt gern hier so ein Abo auf iPhone SE, sollen sie mir einfach immer das Neueste zuschicken, dann bin ich dabei. Aber nicht diese hässlichen Dinger. Also ich meine, sie sollten es tatsächlich hinbekommen, das 7 SE schick zu machen, aber es sieht ja genauso aus wie das 6 SE. Also es ist ja sozusagen genau das selbe.
Wo soll ich jetzt ihren Zeitgeber verlängern? Weil eigentlich war der immer zwei Jahre, und wenn das 7 SE jetzt genauso aussieht, dann ist das schon das dritte Jahr, wo das...
Sie haben jetzt diese Gummiringe jetzt irgendwie oben rum.
Sie haben jetzt alle Designs durch und keinen Steve Jobs, der mehr sagt, jetzt machen wir das.
Vielleicht kommt ja nächstes Jahr auch schon das 8er, weil was soll ich sagen, ja. Jetzt gibt es kein 7S.
Das muss noch schmaler werden.
Nee, weißt du jetzt, wo die Leute alle vorm Gesicht telefonieren? So, dann können sie es jetzt ja auch in die Watch dann direkt einbauen und dann gibt es vielleicht nur noch Watch Phone.
Das verkürzt auch die Gespräche.
Also wenn sie eine korrekte Watch 3, oder Watch 2, oder wie es auch mal heißt, Mark, vorstellen, da wäre ich dabei. Also ich würde so eine GPS-Watch durchaus interessant finden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da ein GPS drin ist. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich glaube, das ist zu fett für so eine kleine Uhr. Also, wenn ich das nicht reinpassen würde, ist ja in vielen anderen Uhren auch drin. Aber dann geht da echt eine Menge Platz für andere Sachen verloren. Also ich weiß nicht, ob die da Platz für so ein GPS-Ding haben.
Und für ein Sturm dafür.
Also eine neue Watch wird auf jeden Fall schneller sein als die alte und das ist schon mal ein Gewinn für das Teil.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also das ist definitiv Geschwindigkeit. Und ich würde mal sagen, da müsste irgendwas mit Faktor 2, Faktor 4 eigentlich drin sein. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein gutes Argument. Wenn man Into-Watches ist oder Into-The-Watches. Aber ich bin ja durchaus schon hooked und von daher...
Ich würde mich ja auch gerne hooken lassen, aber die ist einfach viel zu fett.
Ich glaube nicht mal, dass die dünner wird.
Vielleicht.
Glaub ich nicht.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Aber ich fürchte auch nicht, aber dann ist das nicht so.
Das ist die Batterie im Armband.
Das ist die Watch 3, die wird dann dünner.
Wenn sie dann dicker ist, ist gut. Wenn sie nicht dicker ist, sondern länger lebt, meine ich, dann ist gut. Also selber vor dem Faktor, das geht schon nachher.
Also wenn die Uhr länger lebt, da wäre ich voll...
Bei dir sind das ja nochmal andere Faktoren. Ich frage mich, ob deine Uhr in der Stil-Variante mit diesem Sphinx-Glas besser überlebt hätte. Das wäre echt spannend zu wissen.
Das wäre interessant, aber den AB-Vergleich möchte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt machen.
So, was kommt noch raus? Dann kommt irgendwie iOS 10 raus.
Sierra vielleicht stellen sie vor. Das ist auch fast nichts anderes, außer ihr Siri auf dem Desktop und so blablabla, aber das nutzt doch eh keiner.
Wir sind total...
Wir sind raus, wir sind zu alt.
Ich glaube, Sierra braucht noch ein bisschen, aber...
Ja, aber vorstellen werden sie es doch nochmal, oder?
Ja, aber nicht bei dem Event. Ich glaube, das wird...
Macht aber auch keinen Sinn, das rauszubringen. iOS 10, ich meine, die haben doch wieder aufeinander abgestimmte Sachen, so mit Copy-Paste und so.
Auf die paar Wochen kommt es nicht an.
Nee, die machen das zusammen.
Na, wie ihr meint.
Schauen wir mal, dann sehen wir schon.
Ich will neue Macs haben. Das ist das Einzige, was mich überhaupt noch irgendwie...
Neue Mac Pros.
Eigentlich schon, ja?
Und zwar die gesamte Palette, bitte.
Eigentlich schon.
Make the Mac Pro again.
Make the Mac Mac again.
Ja, genau. Korrekte Airs, korrekte Pros.
Mit Anschlüssen.
Ohne Adaptern. Ja gut, das Thema hatten wir letztes Mal schon. Also das hängt ja dann auch von den Anschlüssen ab.
Und vielleicht doch nochmal ein ordentliches Display.
Man könnte sich ja jetzt dann doch mal auf eins einigen. Bitte?
Ja, ein Display wäre auch gut.
Dentalone.
Hm, genau.
Endlich mal Retina auf dem Schreibtisch haben.
Überhaupt mal irgendwie Retina. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob für mich überhaupt noch, also ob ich es überhaupt noch schaffe in die Retina-Welt. Ich hab genau keinen Retina Mac, nichts.
Ich auch nicht.
Auch nicht. Ich auch nicht.
Hier mit 2012 ist mein Gerät.
Aber du hast Retina.
Richtig, ich hab zwei Retina.
Okay, zwei Retina, drei non-Retina. Also wer uns noch ein Fanboy-Podcast nennt?
Ich hab zwei Retina und zwei non-Retina. Wenn wir jetzt mal die ganz alten Mac-Minis, die irgendwo rumverstauben.
Also mein Telefon ist Retina, aber ich denke, das zählt nicht.
Und bestellt nicht bei Domino Pizza.
Nee, das war wirklich scheiße.
Letty, Onkel, Dennis, Roddy, Timmer. Viel Spaß, viel Glück. Wir sehen uns zwei Wochen, hören uns zwei Wochen. Und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald. Tschüss.